bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du Sénat pour la suite et bien
des hommages le retour sur les attentats
de la semaine dernière vous le savez le
Parlement a bouleversé son ordre du jour
aujourd'hui pour revenir sur ces
attentats il y a eu à l'instant ce
discours à l'Assemblée nationale très
fort du Premier ministre manuel Vals
applaudi à de multiples reprises par
tous les députés gauche et droite
confondu tous les bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale ils se sont tous levés pour
applaudir le Premier ministre le Premier
ministre dans un discours très fort euh
pour dire que la France n'allait pas
baisser évidemment les bras face au
terrorisme et bien le Sénat a également
bouleverser son ordre du jour cet
après-midi avec donc un hommage qui va
être être rendu dans quelques instants
dans dans l'hémicycle du Sénat tout
d'abord avec un discours du président
Gérard Larcher qui va intervenir dans
l'hémicycle pendant une dizaine de
minutes il y aura ensuite une minute de
silence quelques instants de de silence
pour rendre hommage aux victimes des
attentats peut-être que la Marseillaise
sera également chantée dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat comme ça a été le cas tout à
l'heure à 15h après le discours de
Claude Bartelone à l'Assemblée nationale
des parlementaires qui sont évidemment
très touchés comme le sont tous les
Français tous les citoyens français par
ces attentats de de la semaine dernière
des parlementaires qu'on a pu voir
mobiliser à l'Assemblée nationale ils le
sont également au Sénat cet après-midi
des parlementaires émus à la suite du
discours de Gérard Larcher et bien tous
les présidents des groupes politiques du
Sénat prendront la parole ils
s'exprimeront tous pendant 5 minutes
vous pourrez donc entendre dans l'ordre
ellian Assassi pour le groupe communiste
Jacques mzard pour les Radicaux de
Gauche Philippe adnaud pour les non
inscrits au Sénat euh François zoketo
qui est le président du groupe des
centristes Bruno rotaillot pour le
groupe UMP Didier Guillaume le président
des socialistes au Sénat et puis
Jean-Vincent Placé le président du
groupe écologiste ici à la haute à
l'Assemblée après les prises de parole
des présidents des groupes politiques et
bien c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard casazneu qui va venir conclure
ce débat cet hommage aux victimes des
attentats
territ pardon aux victimes des attentats
de de la semaine dernière Bernard
casenuv que nous attendons d'un instant
à l'autre pour pouvoir débuter ici cette
séance au Sénat Bernard casenuf qu'on a
pu voir très ému sur les ban sur le banc
des ministres à l'Assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure lorsque manuel Vals lui a
rendu hommage euh a rendu hommage au
travail qu'il a accompli tous ces
derniers jours dans la traque notamment
des terroristes Bernard casneuf qui a
été applaudi à de pendant un long moment
sur les bancs de l'Assemblée nationale
par tous les députés hein de droite et
de gauche voilà Bernard casenuf qui est
paru très ému et puis à la suite de ce
débat autour des
attentats autour de ces attentats et
bien il y aura un débat sur
l'intervention de la France en en Irak
les sénateurs vont débattre de cette
intervention en Irak et vont voter à
l'issue de cette séance voilà la
sonnerie de l'hémicycle retenti donc je
vous propose de rejoindre l'hémicycle du
cet hommage aux victimes des attentats
la semaine dernière va pouvoir démarrer
je vous l'ai dit par un discours du
président Gérard Larcher il va
s'exprimer et puis à l'issue de ce
discours de Gérard Larcher et bien il y
aura sans doute quelques instants de
silence pour rendre hommage aux victimes
et peut-être que la Marseillaise sera
également chantée dans lesémicic du
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale tout
à l'heure on écoute Gérard la séance est
reprise monsieur le ministre madamees et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je préfère mourir
debout que vivre à genou tels étaient
les propos de Charb nous étions en
septembre
2012 ils sont morts debout
Kabu
bolenski tinus honoré Bernard Maris et
leurs
camarades zakayat Michel Renaud Mustapha
Ourad Frédéric Boissau eux qui n'avaient
que leurs crayons leur carton leurs
convictions leur vie ils ont été frappés
par les balles du fanatisme qui croit
qu'on peut aussi tuer les idées la
liberté
oui liberté celle de penser celle de
s'exprimer celle de dessiner y compris
quand cela nous
dérange Clarissa Jean-Philippe policière
municipale Franck
Brar Ahmed berbet policier sont morts
dans l'exercice de leur fonction ils
sont morts pour l'État de droit pour
l'ordre
républicain victime de leurs
devoirs
johannav
philippeis Michel leurs vie innocent se
sont arrêté par la haine nourrie dans
l'ignorance de l'autre à la veille de la
journée consacrée par eux à la
prière
l'antisémitisme celui de la porte de
Vincen après celui de créteille de
Bruxelles de Toulouse c'est l'antithèse
du village du visage de la France notre
pays s'est
rassemblé je voudrais saluer l'action du
Président de la République du
gouvernement et vous monsieur le
ministre saluer l'esprit de
responsabilité des mouvements politiques
de la majorité comme de
l'opposition la République vient de se
dresser dans cette épreuve et la cheminé
dans un long cortège de
dignité de refus et de silence oui
liberté j'écris ton nom et par le
pouvoir d'un mot je recommence ma vie
ou
vivre ensemble c'est tellement plus fort
que nos différences
oui fraternité n'est pas qu'un mot au
triptique
républicain samedi dimanche ils étaient
les milliers ils été des millions
partout à Paris dans chacune de nos
villes et chacun de nos bourgs pour
crier que la France qui est la nôtre
c'est celle de la
fraternité et que
jamais ne se laisserait aller elle la
France aux complaisances de la haine du
rejet du
fanatisme mais cette levée en masse
cette levée de citoyens nous oblige ces
drames nous oblige à
l'unité il nous oblige au courage il
nous oblige à
l'action nos mains nos esprits ne
peuvent trembler il nous faut
lucidement faire notre devoir d'exigence
absolue il nous faut analyser en
profondeur
comment dans le pays des Lumières peut
se construire une telle expression de la
barbarie et du crime il nous faut
traiter plusieurs questions des
questions concrètes car ce sont aussi
celles auxquelles nos concitoyens
attendent des
réponses la la question de
l'organisation du renseignement la
question du prosélitisme dans nos
prisons la question des réseaux sociaux
utilisés pour véhiculer des messages de
haine que l'on continue à avoir
bourgeoné tels des bubons la question de
l'éducation qu'elle soit à la
citoyenneté ou la connaissance de
l'autre au travers de ses origines de sa
religion ces questionsl et d'autres
encore nous avons le devoir
de les entendre et d'y répondre mes
chers collègues la compassion la
tristesse vont nous étreindre encore ce
matin c'était à la préfecture de police
ce matin c'était aussi à Jérusalem dans
quelques jours ce sera sans doute aux
invalides mais pour que la paix soit
mieux qu'une
incantation répétée avec ferveur il nous
faut agir
agir en nous écoutant les uns les autres
agir aussi dans l'exigence et sans
faiblesse c'est notre devoir de
parlementaire et le Sénat fera son
devoir j'y veillerai et je prendrai les
initiatives qui m'incombent je vous
propose maintenant de nous lever dans un
moment de silence que nous conclurons si
vous le voulez bien par cette qui nous a
rassemblé si nombreux ces jours derniers
et qui est toujours le ciment de la
public
ons enfants de la
Patrie le jour de Loire est
arrivé
onrenous de la
tyranie les Toir sblant
élevés les Toir sblant élevé
enzous dans nos campagnes
mir ses férocces soldat qui vienent
jusque dans n dois et Gorz nos fils et
nos
compagnes aux
am
citoyens
formez vos
bataillons
marchons
car S P
à
noon
merci l'ordre du jour appelle donc le
débat sur les attaques terroristes dont
la France a été victime
et la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Iliane Assassi présidente du
groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens pour 5 minutes madame la
Présidente Monsieur le
Président Mesdames les ministres
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues aujourd'hui le Parlement est
réuni pour rendre hommage à toutes les
victimes des actes terroristes perpétré
du Mercredi 7 Janvier au au siège de
Charlie Hebdo au vendredi 9 janvier avec
l'agression antisémite meurtrière du
magasin Hyper cacher les sénateurs du
groupe communiste républicains et
citoyens qui ont chevillé au corps le
combat pour la liberté de la presse la
liberté d'expression contre toutes les
censures le combat contre
l'antisémitisme la xénophobie et le
racisme s'inclinent devant ses morts
pour la liberté nous apportons notre
soutien notre compassion aux familles
aux proches et à ceux qui blessés
parfois très gravement seront meurtris à
vie par ces actes insensés et
criminels dans cette France soutainement
plongé dans la violence la peur
la formidable mobilisation populaire de
samedi et de dimanche dernier soulève un
immense espoir
uni le peuple a lui aussi rendu hommage
aux victimes il a manifesté sa peine et
affirmé au-delà de la diversité bien
naturelle des messages une profonde
aspiration à vivre ensemble à vivre en
paix une profonde aspiration à faire
respecter
la devise de la de la République
française liberté égalité
fraternité cette vague humaine qui a
déferlé dans tout le pays était
digne profondément Pacifique nul message
de haine n'a pris le dessus vivre libre
penser librement écrire librement
dessiner librement fut le message
dominant je suis Charlie a fait écho au
Liberté j'écrit ton nom de Paul hoir
notre peuple de la Libération a
aujourd'hui a su se lever pour défendre
les valeurs de la République c'est un
événement majeur qui ne pourra pas être
oublié ces millions de femmes et
d'hommes qui sont descendus dans la rue
ont lancé un immense appel au dirigeants
de notre pays au gouvernement aux élus
pour que cela ne se reproduise plus pour
que des mesures forte soit prise afin
que notre société se reconstruise là où
la République vacille et pour que les
idéaux affichés sur les frontons
redeviennent réalité pour tous partout
sur le territoire de la République le
débat démocratique commence et il en va
de nutre responsabilité que de
contribuer à faire fructifier ce qu'il
peut produire de
meilleur cela suppose de condamner de
combattre toutes les formes de
stigmatisation de condamner et de
combattre le racisme de condamner et de
combattre la haine du musulman de
condamner et de combattre
l'antisémitisme oui nous devons faire en
sorte que ce débat se poursuive avec nos
concitoyens et qu'il se poursuive sur le
fond avec eux nous voulons parler de
liberté de laïcité d'égalité de
fraternité de paix de solidarité et bien
sûr avec eux nous voulons aussi débattre
de sécurité car sans sécurité il ne peut
y avoir de liberté comme nous voulons
débattre du monde de la prison de
l'école de la C mais nous vous disons
clairement mes chers collègues que pour
résoudre la crise profonde qui traverse
notre pays que traverse notre pays ces
quartiers populaires il faudra changer
de logique politique donner les moyens
au servicees public en premier lieu à
l'école engager un vaste plan
d'éducation populaire permettra à la
République de réinvestir des zones de
misère sociale tout cela aura un prix
nécessitera des investissements ce n'est
pas le dogme de l'austérité qui
permettra d'apporter une réponse ni même
un début de réponse alors le temps est
encore aujourd'hui au recueillement à
l'émotion à la solidarité mais très vite
il faudra passer à l'action donner du
contenu donner un sens au vivre ensemble
après des décennies de dérégulation
libéral d'individualisme au détriment de
l'intérêt G
il faut marcher ensemble vers une
société plus juste une société plus
solidaire qui place le travail
l'éducation la culture en son cœur et
non plus l'argent roi les sénatrices et
les sénateurs de groupes communistes
républicains et citoyens mèneront ce
combat en mémoire de celles et ceux qui
sont tombés pour la liberté aujourd'hui
ici dans cet hémicycle nous pensons très
fort à eux à leurs famill à leurs
proches à leurs collègues je vous
remercie merci madame la
Présidente la parole est au président
Jacques mzard président du groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européenz la parole
président monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la France et la liberté sont
blessés parce que le premier mot de la
devise nationale est
liberté parce que depuis plus de de
siècles en dépit des guerres des crises
des souffrances de nos erreurs liberté
et France sont indissociablement unis
aux yeux du monde parce que l'attentat a
frappé ceux qui incarnaient au plus haut
degré cette liberté ceux qui est protégé
et des otages martyres la nation s'est
levée criant face à la sauvagerie à la
barbarie il n'est qu'une réponse il n'y
aurait la peur faire face
combattre le choc est d'autant plus fort
que les victimes pleuré sont des hommes
de liberté capables de rire de tout et
d'abord d'eux-mêmes rendant tous les
jours
l'intolérance
ridicule la force de ce cri impose aux
responsables de ce pays de toute
sensibilité d'être à la hauteur du
message
transmis car le temps de la colère
suivra de près le temps de l'émotion si
le temps de l'action n'est pas rapide il
le faut cela a été fait pour châtier les
assassins il doit l'être pouroser les
bases d'une politique de nature à
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
dans une république
apaisée le 11 septembre 1848 Victor Hugo
devant l'Assemblée constituante déclaré
les véritables amis de l'ordre sont
toujours été les plus sérieux amis de la
liberté
oui mes chers collègues il n'est de
démocrati sans
autorité sinon c'est toujours le plus
faible qui sera victime de
l'insécurité l'heure n'est point un
quelconque laxisme ni un angélisme béat
il appartient en premier lieu au pouvoir
exécutif de restaurer l'état son
autorité de ne jamais céder à quelque
violence que ce soit quand quand il
s'agit d'appliquer la loi et les
décisions de
justice voici quelques semaines ici même
je salua et défender l'action de
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
lorsqu'il était injustement dénigré
ainsi que les forces de l'ordre
lesquells ont été applaudis justement
par le peuple ce
dimanche si la loi n'est plus adapté on
la change c'est notre devoir de
législateur mais sinon on l'applique
que doit faire le législateur il doit
concilier ce qui convient aux principes
et ce qui convient aux circonstances
c'est du Denton dans le
texte aujourd'hui nous sommes face à des
phénomènes terroristes en partie inédit
de par la mondialisation de par le
numérique Internet et les réseaux
disoaux cela bouleverse les
comportements facilite le recrutement
direct par les sectes de toute nature et
cela doit inéluctablement nous amener à
adapter la loi à cette révolution dans
les relations humaines Internet ne
saurait être le monde d' endroit un
monde hors la loi cela n'occulte
aucunement la nécessité de donner aux
forces de l'ordre les moyens de leur
action sur le terrain sur tout le
territoire pour mémoire monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur shérif Kashi a
fait un séjour dans mon département en
2010 auprès de son mentor à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres d'une gendarmerie
qui vient d'être supprimée je dis au
gouvernement à notre assemblée qu'il
nous appartient d'examiner rapidement
nos responsabilités sur les causes de
ces drames causes endogènees dans nos
quartiers dans le développement d'un
communautarisme incompatible avec nos
principes républicains facilité par
nombre de discours et de médias dans un
système éducatif débordé comment lutter
contre l'illétrisme dans des classes où
des majorités d'élèves ne parlent pas le
français cause exogène du à la politique
extérieure au Moyen-Orient et au Maghreb
politique d'ingérence dans les
pays-tiers Jacques Chirac le président
Chirac en 2003 avait vu juste ainsi que
son premier ministre l'homme s'est faire
mal à l'homme depuis temps immémorial à
toutes époques quels que soient les
civilisations et les continents les
massacres ont ponctué l'histoire ce qui
change mes chers collègues ce ne sont
que les méthodes ces crimes ont été
commis au nom de Dieu comme cela est
récurrent depuis des siècles et la Pan
des extrémistes de toutes religion 1209
sur notre sol tue-les tous Dieu
reconnaîtra les sien les djihadistes
d'aujourd'hui sont de la même veine
attenté à la vie terrestre pour mériter
la vie éternelle qu'
l'absurdité qualifié dans cette enceinte
de laïque intégriste président du groupe
pour lequel la République laïque et
l'essence même de notre combat politique
je dis ici que oui la République laïque
qui est toujours plus nécessaire pour
garantir les valeurs de la France
qu'aucun gouvernement ne doit céder en
rien à toute dérive
communautaristes plus que d'un
observatoire de la laïcité mesdames et
messieurs les ministres nous avons
impérativement besoin d'une politique
laïque à tous les niveaux la religion
doit demeurer dans la sphère privée ce
qui la protègera c'est cela le vrai
moyen de rejeter le sectarisme
l'intolérance et donc la démocratie pour
que vive la
république merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Philippe annaau délégué des
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe et
ce pour 2 minutes vous avez la parole
mon cher
collègue Bour monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
je souhaite m'associer à l'hommage qui a
été rendu par l'ensemble des citoyens
français aux victimes de cette agression
dont la France a été l'objet aux
victimes innocentes qui n'avaient comme
tort que de se trouver au mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment au policiers
dont nous ne souligneront jamais assez
le dévouement dans un rôle difficile et
dangereux aux membres de la rédaction de
Charlie Hebdo qui n'ont jamais renoncé à
être ce qu'ils étaient malgré le danger
on a le droit d'aimer ou de ne pas aimer
ce qu'il faisait on n'a pas le droit de
s'en prendre à la liberté d'expression
par la violence car au-delà des
personnes c'est bien ce qu'il
symbolisait avec talent la liberté
d'expression ce drame doit nous conduire
à réfléchir au fil des lois des
comportements nous voyons bien qu'il y a
de plus en plus d'Ayatollah de la pensée
unique du politiquement correct tous les
jours nous voyons accroître la liste de
ce qu'il n'est plus possible
d'exprimer cette liberté d'expression
que des millions de Français ont soutenu
comme une valeur fondamentale est tous
les jours remise en cause et pas
seulement par des intégristes religieux
je pense que chacun doit faire son
examen de conscience et malheureusement
je crains que nous ne voyons refleurir
rapidement les interdits au-delà de cet
examen de conscience ici dans notre
société française il faudra bien un jour
que la communauté internationale se
penche sur le cas du conflit
israélo-palestinien qui en plus de la
souffrance infligée à ces deux peuples
nourrit tous les fantasmes dans nos ban
e et sert de paravant au terrorisme
international soyons lucide rien n'est
résolu par la grande manifestation des
Français il faudra bien examiner les
dysfonctionnements entrevus pas pour
désigner des coupables mais Identifier
les manquements le tueur de Vincen a été
relâché au bout de 1 an et demi alors
qu'il avait 5 ans de peine partout la
République recule dans son exigence de
laïcité l'exemple de la de silence dans
les établissements scolaires est
flagrant je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait
besoin de nouvelles lois mais plutôt
qu'il faudrait revoir les conditions de
leur application pensons à ce policier
déclarant je les ai eu parlant des
frères coiffi je les ai eu pendant 10
secondes dans mon viseur mais je n'étais
pas en état de légitime défense je pense
aussi qu'il y a un problème de moyen
lorsque nous voyons parfois sur nos
territoire des véhicules de gendarmerie
immobilisé faute d'essence je voudrais
enfin terminer par un hommage aux forces
de l'ordre leur courage leur
détermination leur sang-froid force
notre admiration nous sommes fiers d'eux
et pour cela nous devons les soutenir
mais nous devrons aussi les soutenir
demain je ne vous demande aucun
applaudissement pour mon intervention
mais je vous les demande pour
eux
merci mon cher collègue la parole est au
président François zooketo président du
groupe Union des démocrates et
indépendants Union centriste vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les les
ministres mes chers collègues assassiné
pour s'être exprimé assassiné pour avoir
choisi de défendre leur
concitoyens assassiné pour leurs
confessions religieuses tel est le
sinistre bilan des attentats de la
semaine
dernière face à cette violence je tiens
à saluer le sang-froid le
professionnalisme de tous les agents de
nos force de
sécurité je salue aussi l'ensemble des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement qui nous
ont apporté leur solidarité et celle de
leur compatriote mais évidemment je
salue au plus haut le peuple français
dans sa réaction de dignité d'unité de
sagesse l'objectif des barbares est
d'instaurer leurs lois en créant la la
peur
l'insécurité mais mes chers collègues
nous sommes ici nous sommes debout
ensemble et nous le crions et nous
l'avons
chanté il nous faut nous parlementaires
être désormais à la hauteur de nos
compatriotes nous sommes confrontés à la
nécessité
d'agir le travail du Parlement sur ce
sujet doit être rappeler une commission
d'enquête est à l'œuvre ici au Sénat
depuis plus plusieurs mois à la demande
d'ailleurs de notre groupe udi UC s'il
faut accroître les moyens de cette
commission d'enquête nous devons tous y
être favorabl me
semble-t-il nos collègues nous feront
des
propositions mais n'oublions pas que la
loi ne règle pas
tout pensons surtout à donner au service
en charge de protéger les Français les
moyens requis moyens juridiques bien
bien sûr mais moyen humains et moyen
matériel plus que
jamais face à la contrainte budgétaire
tant rappeler sachons assumer cette
priorité la réflexion qui s'engage devra
aborder la question
pénitentiare il est primordial que nos
prisons ne deviennent pas des centres de
radicalisation on ne peut pas accepter
qu'un délinquant soit incarcéré par une
décision de justice et que son séjour en
prison fasse de lui un terroriste en
puissance il nous faut donc accepter que
les moyens de l'administration
pénitentiaire soi largement renforcés si
l'on veut endiguer ses
dérives mais la lutte contre le
terrorisme débute bien en amont elle
débute en refusant de laisser tout
espace au
fondamentaliste notre lutte contre le
fanatisme contre l'obscurantisme
doit bien sûr être un rappel incessant
de nos grands principes mais elle doit
aussi d'abord et surtout être un combat
dans notre terrain dans nos terrains
quotidiens plus que jamais il nous faut
être au côté des
enseignants des médecins des personnels
de nos hôpitaux des gardiens de prison
des agents de nos mairies de nos
collectivités confrontés malheureusement
au quotidien à l'intolérance au
négationnisme à la misogynie à
l'antisémitisme même et surtout le
territoire il nous faut être
suffisamment fier des valeurs de la
République pour refuser les compromis
voir toutes ces compromissions du
quotidien dans lesquelles se répand la
radicalité et plus en amont encore il
nous faut nous poser les questions qui
vont bien sûr nous gêner quels sont les
ressorts qui poussent certains de nos
enfants certains Français a basculé dans
une telle haine de notre société et de
notre pays de leur pays sans céder à la
culture de l'excuse bien sûr et en étant
fermement attaché aux notions d'autorité
qui ont été rappelés déjà à cette
tribune il nous faut voir quelle
frustration quelles humiliations qu
lacune familiale et quelle lacune
sociétale aussi sont à l'œuvre pour
arriver à un tel
résultat alors bien sûr les réponses ne
sont pas simples mais elles sont
indispensables à apporter rapidement si
nous voulons que les victime de la
semaine dernière ne soit pas morte pour
rien
merci
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant président Bruno rotaillot
président du groupe Union pour un
mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
madamees messieurs les ministres mes
chers
collègues depuis dimanche dernier plus
que jamais nous sommes Fiè nous sommes
fiers d'être français nous en sommes
fiers car la République française s'est
révélé plus forte que le terrorisme et
nous en sommes fiers car la nation
française n'est jamais aussi belle et
aussi grande que lorsque les Français
sont réunis dimanche les Français sont
redevenus un peuple un grand peuple à la
face du monde uni dans cette émotion
nationale uni dans l'hommage l'hommage à
nos morts ceux de Charlie hebdau les
otages otages parce qu'ils étaient juifs
les policiers unis dans cette
mobilisation nationale qui a rassemblé
tant de Français de toutes origines de
toutes conditions et qui emble tant à la
France car dimanche dernier nous avons
tous marché contre le terrorisme mais
nous avons aussi marché pour la France
pour cette grande passion française qui
est la liberté cette liberté que les
Français revendiqu pour
eux pour eux-mêmes cette liberté
d'expression qui est d'abord et avant
tout l'expression d'une liberté
fondamentale la liberté de conscience de
croire ou de ne pas croire cette liberté
que les Français revendiquent aussi pour
le monde comme le disait le Général de
Gaulle il existe un Pact 20 fois
séculaire entre la grandeur de la France
et la liberté du monde et c'est au nom
de ce pacte que la France est
aujourd'hui attaquée que notre pays est
aujourd'hui en
guerre il faut le dire car mal nommer
les choses c'est ajouter au malheur du
monde comme l'écrivait si bien Camu et
après cette tragédie nous n'avons pas le
droit nous les représentants de la
nation d'ajouter au malheur de la France
bien sûr cette guerre n'est pas une
guerre conventionnelle c'est une guerre
radicalement nouvelle ça n'est pas une
guerre entre les nations notre ennemi se
moque des frontières il frappe à
l'Orient dans l'Occident au cœur même de
Paris ce n'est pas non plus une guerre
de religion car la barbarie n'a pas de
religion jamais ceux qui professent la
haine de l'autre ne pourront parler au
d'une espérance mais c'est bien d'une
guerre dont il s'agit une guerre
nouvelle qui prospère sur une situation
nouvelle nationale
internationale nationale car notre
société est aujourd'hui au prise avec de
nouvelles formes de radicalité oui c'est
l'exemple de cette jeunesse déboussolée
fanatisée hypnotisée par cette
fascination morbide pour l'absolue
radicalité du mal cette jeunesse qui a
grandi chez nous sur le sol français et
qui fait le voyage pour le djihad
international aussi car toutes les
grandes puissances peinent aujourd'hui à
combattre le terrorisme islamiste qui a
changé de nature puisqu'il s'est glissé
dans les habits de la mondialisation il
est à la fois déterritorialisé et il
cherche à s'enraciner il est diffus et
en même temps connecté un terrorisme qui
a également changé d'expression
puisqu'il ne se contente plus de se
livrer et de livrer une guerre militaire
mais aussi une guerre d'information
à travers la révolution numérique nous
devons donc oui nous devons nous donner
les moyens juridiques budgétaire mais
aussi politique de mener et de gagner
cette guerre les moyens juridiques en
adaptant notre arsenal tout notre
arsenal juridique à l'évolution de la
menace monsieur le ministre c'est la
raison pour laquelle la Commission
d'enquête sénatoriale sur l'organisation
et les moyens de lutte contre les
réseaux djihadistes doit être renforcé
dans son périmètre dans ses missions
pour apporter des réponses concrètes à
ces interrogations qui sont celles de
millions de Français comment cela a-t-il
pu être possible quelle mesure efficace
pour que cela ne se reproduise pas tout
doit être
réévalué en fonction de cette menace qui
pourrait encore
frapper sur toutes ces questions je
souhaite que le Sénat au-delà et bien
au-delà des clivages traditionnels
puisse faire des propositions au
gouvernement car les Français exigent la
vérité ils exigent la fermeté ils
exigent aussi d'être protégés ils en ont
le droit et nous en avons le
devoir moyen juridique et budgétaire
donc mais moyens politiqu également
après cette tragédie il n'y a plus de
place pour
l'angélisme la mobilisation nationale ne
doit pas en effet occulter ce qui s'est
produit aussi c'est derniers jours dans
des
écoles sur internet le refus de
participer à la minute de
silence et toutes ces réactions font
écho à d'autres refus communautaires
identitaire dans l'espace public au
mépris de toutes nos valeurs de liberté
de laïcité bien sûr non la France mes
chers collègu la France ne sera jamais
un archipel de tribu de communautarisme
la France n'est pas non plus une Jux
positionition d'individus nous devons
trouver nous devons trouver comment
redonner le goût de la France à tous ces
jeunes Français mais nous devons aussi
regarder les choses en face car si nous
baissons les yeux devant le
communautarisme alors nous baisserons
les bras aussi devant l'islamisme et
nous n'avons pas le droit de baisser les
bras parce qu'il s'agit de la France car
dans ce combat pour la liberté France
doit rester ce soldat de l'idéal dont
avait si bien parlé George clémenau à la
tribune de l'Assemblée le 11 novembre
1918 c'est parce que nous sommes ce
soldat que nous devons mener cette
guerre cette guerre que nous devons
gagner pour la République pour la
sécurité des Français et pour la liberté
des hommes vive la république et vive la
france merci monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant au président
Didier Guillaume président du groupe
socialiste et
apparentéz la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre de l'Intérieur mesdames et
messieurs les ministres l'année 2015 a
commencé dans le sang 17 morts 17 morts
pour la France ils étaient agents de
maintenance journalistes
dessinateurs policiers psychiatres
économistes correcteurs cadrees
commercial employés de supermarché
étudiants retraités ils étaient ils
représentaient la France dans toute sa
diversité sociale d'origine de croyance
et d'opinion après l'UDU attentat contre
la rédaction de Charlie Hebdo c'est une
véritable atteinte à la liberté de la
presse que nous condamnons
ils ont été tués parce qu'ils
dessinaient librement après l'assassinat
de la policière municipale et la lâche
exécution dans la rue du policier c'est
une véritable atteinte à la République
que nous condamnons ils ont été tués
parce qu'il représentaiit l'état après
l'attaque antisémite et la prise d'otage
sanglante de l'hyper cacher c'est une
véritable atteinte à à la religion juive
que nous condamnons ils ont été tués
parce qu'ils étaient juifs c'est la
Nation toute entière qui a été visée la
France a été attaquée pour ce qu'elle
est et pour ce qu'elle fait la France
pays des Lumières la France qui a su
faire la révolution la France qui a
toujours réussi à combattre
l'obscurantisme d'où qu'il viennent où
qu'il soit c'est cette France là que
l'on aime oui nous sommes fiers d'être
français oui nous sommes fiers de la
France l'objectif des terroristes et
d'instiler le doute dans nos consciences
nous faire peur mais la France n'a pas
peur elle n'a pas peur comme écrivait le
général de Gaulle dans l'appel du 18
juin la France doit rester digne debout
fire de son héritage la mobilisation des
citoyens tel que notre pays n'en a
jamais connu a été une réponse à une
tragédie qui a touché la France dans sa
chair et la République laïque dans ses
symboles le peuple français a répondu à
la barbarie par la Frat
dans les rues de tout le pays de toutes
nos villes et nos villages il faut
malheureusement des événements
dramatiques pour que nous prenions
conscience collectivement de ce que nous
sommes pour ce que nous nous fédérions
derrière le drapeau tricolore en
chantant la Marseillaise oui nous aimons
ce que nous sommes et nous l'avons clamé
haut et fort jusqu'à la face du monde
gloire à nos forces de l'ordre à ces
hommes et ses femmes de sacrific oui la
France a un étatat fort les Français
l'ont vu à l'œuvre je rends hommage à
tous ceux qui ont agi et qui agissent
encore pour nous défendre policiers
gendarmes force de renseignement qui
nous protège au quotidien aux
responsables politiques qui prennent les
décisions l'État a été efficace le chef
de l'État était à la hauteur de cet
événement à la fois national et mondial
il a été le garant la première
incarnation de l'unité nationale il
représentait la France le Premier
ministre a coordonné l'action du
gouvernement avec exemple é et sérénité
il a été le moteur efficace de la
cohérence gouvernementale le ministre de
l'Intérieur a agi avec rapidité et
fermeté il a démontré ses immenses
qualités de sang frroid et d'efficacité
sincère félicitations monsieur le
ministre cher Bernard
casenu
vous avez fait honneur à la République
Monsieur le Ministre nous pouvons tous
ressentir une cette fierté en ces
périodes agitées il nous faut garder la
tête froide ne sombrons pas dans la
tentation du tout sécuritaire mais ne
soyons pas naïf pour autant le groupe
socialiste n'est pas favorable à un
patriote acte à la française comme l'ont
fait les États-Unis d'Amérique en 2001
nous n'y sommes pas favorables parce que
nous sommes la France des voix se sont
élevées pour réclamer la restauration de
la peine de mort l'abolition de la peine
de mort c'est notre patrimoine
républicain c'est notre identité c'est
notre civilisation la peine de mort ne
sera jamais rétablie dans notre
pays mais ne sombrons pas pour autant
dans l'angéisme s'il y a des mesures
exceptionnelles à prendre contre le
terrorisme nous les voterons
les Français attendent des réponses à la
hauteur de ces attentats au dieux des
mesures exceptionnelles oui des mesures
d'exception non liberté et sécurité
voilà comment nous entendons travailler
au côté du gouvernement notre identité
c'est la liberté c'est la République
c'est l'humanisme la sécurité est un
droit fondamental pour chacun de nous
notamment ceux qui sont le plus exposés
notre jeunesse l'espère nos quartiers
l'attendent nos concitoyens la réclament
notre nation tout enti il y a droit nous
ne sommes pas en guerre contre une
civilisation nous ne sommes pas en
guerre contre une religion et je veux
avoir à l'instant une pensée pour tous
les musulmans de France et leur dire que
nous ne faisons pas
d'amalgam la France ne serait rien sans
les juifs les musulmans les Ath les
croyants ou les non croyants mais la
France ne serait rien sans la laïcité
oui la France est laïque cette laïcité
qui permet à chacun de pratiquer ou de
ne pas pratiquer un culte la laïcité ce
ciment des différences qui permet
l'égalité dans la République la laïcité
qui est le fondement de notre pacte
républicain celui du vivre ensemble nous
sommes toutes et tous attendus mes chers
collègues notre mobilisation a été
saluée par les Français alors
travaillons la mise en avant de nos
valeurs fondamentales liberté égalité
fraternité gage d'une meilleure prise de
conscience de notre appartenance à notre
nation commune partageons ensemble
optimisme et détermination pour la
République et pour la France je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le
Président la parole est au président
Jean-Vincent Placé président du groupe
écologiste je suspend quel
vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président du Sénat
au nom du groupe écologiste je tiens à
vous remercier pour les mots que vous
avez eu qui sont à la hauteur des
circonstances tragique qui nous
rassemble ici je aussi saluer l'action
du Président de la République et du
Premier ministre la vôtre aussi monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur dans cette
épreuve vos actions ont été efficaces
aux paroles rassembleuses V comportement
d'une grande dignité je veux aussi
saluer l'ensemble des formations
politiques républicaines de leur sens
fond des responsabilités dans ce temps
si tragique pour le pays c'était
indispensable dans ces trois jours
terribles durant lesqueles ce sont la
liberté d'expression l'autorité de
l'État et la laïcité qui ont été touché
au cœur en un mot la République la
liberté d'expression d'abord les
journalistes de Charlie Hebdo certains
dans notre groupe les connaissaient bien
était pacifique et généreux avec leur
disparition c'est un pays qui est sous
le choc l'attentat don dont ils ont été
victimes nous oblige à affronter une
réalité terrible on risque de mourir
dans notre pays la France pour avoir
fait un dessin irrévérentieux sur mahomé
une réalité inacceptable cruelle
insoutenable liberté fondamentale la
liberté d'expression est indissociable
de la liberté d'opinion de la liberté de
pensere c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne céderons jamais rien sur ce
droit alors au groupe écologiste et ici
tous les sénateurs nous sommes tous
Charlier l'autorité de l'État nos forces
de scurité ont payé un lourd tribu dans
ses jours sombres avec deux policiers et
une policière municipal assassiné notre
reconnaissance profonde va aux agents du
GIGN du raid de la B qui ont mis leur
vie en péril certains ont été blessés
pour sauver les otages et mettre un
terme à la cavale de ces
meurtriers notre reconnaissance va aux
gendarmes policiers militaires à la
protection civile mobilisé encore en ce
moment même dans le cadre du Plan vigil
pirate écarlate il mérite tout notre
respect nous sommes tous ici des
policiers la laïcité enfin quatre
personnes sont mortes uniquement parce
qu'elles étaient juives nous devons
toujours lutter inlassablement contre
l'antisémitisme chacun de nos
concitoyens quelle que soit sa
confession son origine doit pouvoir
vivre libre et en sécurité en France ce
droit cette liberté c'est à l'État c'est
à la France de la garantir C'est ça la
vraie laïcité
oui il y a un temps
pour le recueillement nos pensées les
plus bouleversées vont à ceux qui ont
perdu la vie au blessés certains le sont
encore grièvement à leur famille à leurs
proches nous ne les oublierons jamais il
y a un temps pour la mobilisation le
peuple qui s'est dressé dimanche crayon
au point a initié une manifestation
inédite et digne soutenue dans le monde
entier cette mobilisation ne doit
surtout pas retomber et c'est à nous
responsablebles politique de la faire
vivre cette mobilisation et y a il y
aura un temps pour la réflexion
doit aussi prendre son temps chacun sait
que le drame ne s'est pas terminé
malheureusement vendredi nous sommes en
droit de craindre d'autres violences
comment protéger notre République
quelles actions immédiates quelle
politique dans la durée président
Larcher dans son intervention a posé les
bonnes questions auxquelles il nous
faudra effectivement apporter des
réponses mais face au terrorisme la
réponse les réponses ne peuvent être que
globales collectives
solidaires il nous faudra continuer jour
après jour à mobiliser tout le pays dans
toutes ces composantes politiques
religieuses en particulier nos
compatriotes musulmans philosophiques et
citoyennes tous nos amis et alliés en
Europe et dans le monde qui sont venus
si vite mobiliser solidairement à nos
côtés ce dimanche auprès du chef de
l'État qu'ils en soi ici remercier
chaleureusement cette attaque en règle
contre nos valeurs app à l'unité
nationale et à la défense de valeurs que
nous croyons intouchable l'unité du pays
le rassemblement des Français voilà une
condition tout simplement
cineéquanon pas seulement aujourd'hui
mais également demain et après-demain on
le sait cette unité nationale est si
fragile et je forme le vœux ici
aujourd'hui à la tribune du Sénat de la
République que nous sachions la
préserver à chaque instant comme notre
bien commun le plus précieux je forme le
vœux que nous toutes et tous sénateur
sénatrice de la République française
nous sachions nous élever comme l'ont
fait le gouvernement et le peuple
français à la hauteur des enjeux et des
dangers auxquels nous devons faire face
et tous ensemble nous sommes tous
Charlie nous sommes tous policiers nous
sommes tous Juifs vive la France et vive
la république
merci monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Bernard
casenuve ministre de
l'Intérieur
monsieur le Président du Sénat mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs les
ministres je m'exprime avec vous
aujourd'hui dans une immense
émotion l'émotion que j'ai ressenti dans
vos propos monsieur le Président du
Sénat très juste très profond qui
rappelait ce que nous sommes ce que sont
les valeurs de la République et ce qui
nous rassemble dans cet hémicycle et
pard là cette cycle dans le pays j'ai
retrouvé cette
émotion cette force dans les
interventions de tous ceux qui se sont
succédés à la tribune quelle que soit la
formation politique à laquelle ils
appartiennent j'ai ressenti cette
émotion et cette force aussi dans le
discours qu'a
prononcé le Premier ministre avec une
force exceptionnelle tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons tous
ressenti cette émotion dimanche dans les
rues de Paris alors que derrière les
victimes rassemblé dans la dignité il y
avait des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement venus de toute l'Union
européenne mais de bien au-delà autour
du président de la République française
qui était venu dire leur amour de la
France et à travers leur amour de la
France leur attachement aux valeurs que
nous incarnons qui sont des valeurs
universelles qui les concernent et qui
les ontpir parfois lorsqu'ils ont mis en
place leurs
institutions nous étions nombreux
représentants des institutions des corps
constitués mais aussi simples citoyens à
dire que nous n'avions pas peur que face
au terrorisme nous étions debout
déterminé à faire prévaloir ce que nous
sommes dans la fermeté dans l'exigence
de voir prévaloir à chaque instant les
valeurs de la République et dans la
volonté de faire en sorte qu'à tout
moment la la sécurité des Français et
notamment de ceux qui ont été atteints
soit assurés nous avons tous à l'esprit
vos propos en témoignent l'importance du
drame qui s'est produit la semaine
dernière un drame qui a touché des
journalistes des caricaturistes des
dessinateurs parce qu'avec leur crayons
ils étaient les héritier de l'esprit de
Voltaire celui qui a inspiré Micromégas
qui regardait notre pays de sirrius et
parfois par la distance qu'il créait de
là où il nous regardait parvenait à
déceler ce qui en nous méritait d'être
corrigé ou dénoncé et bien le crayon de
ces caricaturistes était leur manière à
eux de témoigner de leur impertinence et
de créer entre eux leur égard et la
réalité cette distance dont nous avons
besoin parfois pour nous changer
nous-mêmes cette impertinence cette
liberté c'est ce qu'on a voulu atteindre
cette impertinence cette liberté c'est
la France de domier à volinski Cabu et
tant d'autres qui par leur talent
témoignent de l'amour que nous avons de
la liberté on a voulu atteindre des
policiers des policiers nationaux et les
policiers
municipaux parce que dans la République
ils incarnent le droit qu'ils incarnent
l'ordre quand je dis l'ordre je ne veux
pas parler d'une fermeture d'une rigueur
d'une rigidité non je veux parler de
l'amour de la République du droit de
l'État de droit qui constitue notre
patrimoine commun je veux vous parler de
ces policiers je vous en parler parce
qu'ils ont été en première ligne dans
ces événements et comme vous l'avez dit
les uns et les autres justement il
mérite notre estime et notre
considération je vais vous parler des
camarades membres du service de
protection des hautes personnalités de
Franck qui assuré la protection de
Stéphane Charbonnier
dicharbe et qui est tombé quelques
minutes après l'entrée des terroristes
dans les locaux de Charlie
Hebdo la
main sur son
pistolet pour assurer courageusement la
protection de celui dont il avait la
charge je n'oublierai jamais
jamais les larmes de ces camarades du
Service de protection des hautes
personnalités qui savaient son courage
sa droiture et sa valeur comme je
n'oublierai jamais le regard déterminé
de sa mère ce matin à la cérémonie
disant sa détermination à résister à la
peur dans la dignité je n'oublierai
jamais
lesffroids des camarades de la jeune
policière municipale de
Montrouge qui venaient d'assister au
crime abject on avait tiré dans le dos
de leurs
camarades il y avait pardelà les larmes
la colère et
l'indignation je n'oublierai jamais non
plus le visage et les regard des
policiers du commissariat du 11e
arrondissement les camarades du policier
Ahmed qui a essayé de s'intercepter
après que le crime a été commis dans les
locaux de Charlie Hebdo pour faire en
sorte que la fuite funeste
s'arrête il y avait dans ce regard de la
tristesse une tristesse incommensurable
il y avait dans ses regards la fierté
d'être policier et je n'oublierai non
plus jamais le regard parfois derrière
le masque qui assure leur protection il
ne faut pas qu'on les reconnaisse qu'on
les distingue qu'on les identifie les
regards des policiers de la berie et du
raid qui sont intervenus en sauvant
toutes les vies qui pouvait l'être à
l'épicerie hyper cachère et
qui témoignait ses regards non pas de la
peur après s'être engagé non pas de
l'effroid et pourtant il dut à un moment
être rencontré mais qui témoignait
simplement de la fierté d'avoir sauvé
des vies
alors ces hommes ces femmes qui
constituent nos forces de l'ordre que
j'ai eu sous ma responsabilité pendant
ces événement tragique je veux de cette
tribue notement symbolique leur leur
dire du fond du cœur mon immense mon
incommensurable gratitude et
l'exprimant
et l'expriment ainsi de cette tribune je
sais que elle n'est que l'expression de
ce que vous éprouvez chacune et chacun
car nombreux ont été vos
témoignages vos lettres vos appels vos
SMS et je n'oublierai jamais non plus à
quel point dans cette période vous avez
été proche de celles et de ceux qui
assurent la sécurité des Français et à
vous aussi sénateur et sénatrices de
France pour cette
solidarité pour cet amour de la
République je veux dire ma gratitude et
mes
remerciements et puis je n'oublierai
jamais non plus les propos qui ont été
tenus par les représentants des
institutions et de la communauté juive
de France qui nous ont dit leur
lassitude et leur tristesse d'avoir peur
parce qu'il voit l'antisémitisme
ressurgir dans des formes qui donnent le
sentiment que jamais les choses ne
s'arrêteront et que jamais il ne sera
mis fin à l'abjection et bien comme l'a
dit le Premier ministre tout à l'heure à
la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale avec
force je veux avec vous leur dire d'ici
que nous n'accepterons plus et que nous
mettrons tout en œuvre pour que plus
jamais un seul Juif de France n'it peur
d'aller dans une école dans un lieu de
culte parce qu'il y a des barbares et
des assassins qui veulent s'attaquer à
ce qu'il y a de plus précieux dans notre
pays le droit de croire ou de ne pas
croire et dès lors que l'on a fait le
choix de sa religion de pouvoir la
pratiquer en sécurité et en liberté et
dimanche
et dimanche lorsque nous étions ensemble
dans les rues de
Paris nous avons ressenti le peuple de
France qui prenait dans ses bras
par-delà les victimes qui conduisaient
le
cortège tous les journalistes de France
qui incarnent en France la liberté et
qui la font vivre dans la République
tous les policiers de France gendarmes
nationaux et municipaux qui assurent
l'ordre et font respecter l'État de
droit tous les Juifs de France qui
aiment profondément la République et
n'entendent pas qu'on l'teigne mais
aussi tous les autres qui peuvent avoir
honte qui peuvent avoir peur et qui
n'entendent pas que dans la République
on crée la division l'effroid et la peur
alors bien entendu comme l' dit le
Premier ministre à l'Assemblée nationale
comme l'a exprimé ce matin encore une
fois avec beaucoup de force le président
de la République comme vous l'avez
exprimé vous-même à l'instant il nous
faut maintenant regarder l'avenir et
tirer tous les enseignements de ce qui
s'est produit et je veux vous dire dans
la responsabilité qui est la mienne de
ministre de l'intérieur mais le Premier
ministre a indiqué tout à l'heure que
c'était là un devoir pour l'ensemble du
gouvernement que nous nous tenons à la
disposition des assemblées non seulement
pour expliquer non seulement pour rendre
compte la démocratie doit continuer a
respirer avec cette exigence et je
dirais même que cette exigence de rendre
compte doit être encore plus forte
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
qu'elle n'a pu l'être par le passé
lorsque des événements difficiles se
sont produits en raison de la dimension
de drame de tragédie mais aussi parce
que c'est ensemble que nous devons tirer
les enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
pour apporter les justes corrections les
justes évolutions et faire en sorte que
nous soyons plus forts et plus armé
encore face au risqu terroristes alors
je voudrais comme l'a fait le premier
ministre tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée
nationale esquisser devant vous
simplement rapidement parce que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en reparler souvent
et et prochainement les quelques pistes
sur lesquelles nous avons décidé
d'avancer ensemble d'abord il y a
l'urgence pour moi l'urgence ce sont
deux sujets d'abord l'enquête qui se
poursuit nous avons mis en place et
c'est été des raisons du succès des
opérations qui ont été conduites une
cellule
opérationnelle destinée à assurer le bon
déroulement des enquêtes placées sous
l'autorité du parquet antiterroriste et
à mettre hors d'état de nuire tous ceux
qui ont qui qui avaient commis des actes
o pouvait en commettre encore nous avons
décidé à la demande du Président de la
République du Premier ministre de ne pas
désarmer cette cellule opérationnelle de
crise qui rassemble plusieurs fois par
jour autour de moi l'ensemble des grands
dirigeants du ministère de l'Intérieur
qui travaillent ensemble etchangent les
informations de manière à ce que les
enquête se poursuivent avance vite et
permettent d'identifier toutes les
complicités et l'identité de tous ceux
qui ont pu participer contribuer aux
actes tragiques de la semaine dernière
afin qu'il soit identifié et mis hors
d'état de nuire vous comprendrez qu'il
ne serait pas responsable de ma part de
donner des les éléments sur ces enquêtes
en cours placé sous l'autorité du
procureur de Paris du parquet
antiterroriste mais je veux vous
rassurer en vous disant que tout est mis
en œuvre pour que ces enquêtes
progressent et qu'ell permettent
d'atteindre le but comme je veux vous
assurer de la détermination de tous les
services qui sont placés sous ma
responsabilité notamment de la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure de
tout mettre en œuvre pour que nous
puissions identifier l'ensemble de ceux
qui peuvent représenter un danger pour
notre pays car nous sommes et il faut
nommer les choses les regarder en face
avec sangfroid et détermination face à
un terrorisme d'un nouveau type des
combattants étranger en nombre dont le
nombre a augmenté de près de 80 % depuis
le début de l'année qui partent sur le
théâtre des
opérations terroristes notamment en Irak
et en Syrie et reviennent après avoir
procédé à des exactions des exécution
des décapitations et qui se trouvent
animé conduit dirigé par le seul
instinct de la haine il y a tous ceux
qui sont organisés au sein d'autres
structures je pense notamment à
Al-Qaïda et qui peuvent à travers
d'autres
modalités frapper encore et à tout
moment il y a ceux qui n'appartiennent à
rien mais qui fréquentent dans une
relation exclusive de tout autre la
violence sur Internet et qui peuvent
seul sans avoir été commandé par
personne passer à l'acte en commettant
des crimes ils sont d'ailleurs les plus
difficiles à détecter et puis il y a des
cellules dormantes et puis il y a des
réseaux organisés du crime du trafic
d'armes et du trafic de drogue qui
aliment par leur financement ces réseaux
organisés terroristes et qui doivent
être démantelés je veux vous dire
clairement nettement fermement la
détermination du gouvernement à agir
sans trêve ni pause pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de sanctuaire en France pour ces
acteur du crime queles que soient les
activités auxquelles ils se livrent et
que les services qui sont placés sous ma
responsabilité sont déterminés à
atteindre le but en multipliant les
actions et les initiatives comme ils le
font depuis des mois et je veux vous
demander
solennellement
de poser toutes les questions parce
qu'ils sont déterminés à y répondre et
en même temps de
comprendre que face au risques auquel
nous sommes
confrontés notre mobilité doit être
grande notre capacité d'adaptation
constante et notre détermination
totale poursuivre les enquêtes assurer
la sécurité des Français par l'action de
nos services de renseignement et aussi
assurer la protection des lieux et des
instituts
qui peuvent se trouver
frappé par ces assassins et ces barbares
je pense au lieu de culte je pense à
certaines écoles je pense à certaines
institutions c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons pris la décision de
protéger l'ensemble des écoles et des
lieux de culte de la communauté juive à
sa demande et en liaison étroite avec
elle mais ai tous les autres parce que
les actes islamophobes se sont
multipliés au cours des derniers jours
et des dernières semaines et qu'il est
du devoir de la République de protéger
tous ses enfants et de traquer ceux qui
veulent s'attaquer aux valeur de la
République à ses principes et de faire
en sorte aussi comme l'ont dit beaucoup
d'orateurs qu'à cette fin nous soyons
intransigeents comme l'a dit le Premier
ministre avec beaucoup de force tout à
l'heure dans le respect des principes de
la laïcité poursuivre les enquêtes
assurer dans l'urgence la sécurité et
puis nous armer
davantage et pour nous armer d'avantage
nous devons traiter de trois questions
elles ont été évoquées tout à l'heure
elle doit être traitée au fond et en
très étroite concertation avec
l'ensemble des groupes représentés à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat c'est
l'esprit de la réunion que j'ai tenu
hier place bovau qui en a appellera
d'autres d'autres que nous devrons tenir
dans l'urgence car la réponse comme vous
l'avez dit les uns et les autres ne
saurait trop attendre les trois sujets
sur lesquels le Premier ministre a
proposé que nous engagions la réflexion
collective et sur laquelle il m'a
demandé avec d'autres membres du
gouvernement de travailler sont les
suivants d'abord la question des
moyens nous sommes dans une période qui
doit durer le plus longtemps possible
d'unité de concorde nationale parce que
l'unité nationale comme vous l'avez dit
les uns et les autres et la condition de
la force face aux attaques terroristes
alors il n'est pas le moment
et il ne sera jamais le moment dans
cette période de faire le bilan de
décisions prises par les uns et les
autres à tel ou tel
moment nos forces de sécurité ont perdu
des moyens nous sommes ensemble
déterminés à faire en sorte qu'elles en
retrouvent c'est l'esprit des décisions
prises par le gouvern gouvernement au
début du quinquena lorsqu'il a décidé de
procéder à des recrutements nouveaux
dans la police et dans la gendarmerie au
sein de la Direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure dont 50 % des
effectifs se consacre à la lutte
antiterroriste 432 postes on ont
été envisagés dont la moitié sont d'ors
et déjà créé il en faudra sans doute
plus le Premier ministre m'a demandé
dans cet esprit de lui faire des
propositions nous avons besoin
d'ingénieurs de techniciens
d'informaticiens pour mieux détecter un
certain nombre de filières qui agissent
sur les réseaux Internet mieux résister
aussi à un certain nombre d'attaques
cyber dont nous pouvons faire
l'objet nous avons également besoin de
conforter nos moyens hors les personnels
12 millions d'euros ont été affectés
dans le cadre du prochain triénal par an
à la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure pour améliorer ses capacités
technologiques d'intervention
j'avais indiqué au Premier ministre au
cours des dernières semaines qu'il me
paraissait nécessaire d'aller au-delà
dans la modernisation des
infrastructures informatique du
ministère de l'intérieur des
infrastructures des réseaux des
applications car un certain nombre de
défaillances qui avaient été constaté
notamment la défaillance du système kops
à l'occasion du retour des trois
combattants étrangers aant transité par
la Syrie était le signe d'un
sous-investissement chronique dans les
moyens informatiques dont nous avons
besoin pour assurer la sécurité nous
allons procéder là aussi à des
investissements significatifs qui seront
proposé dans le cadre du plan que je
présenterai au Premier ministre dans
quelques jours les moyens ce sont aussi
ces moyens qui doivent permettre à nos
forces d'être véloces rapide réactiv
lorsque des incidents graves se
produisent vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la question des véhicules ce
n'est pas un petit sujet 40 millions
d'euros sont d'ors et déjà affectés par
force pour permettre l'achat de 2000
véhicules par an cet effort doit se
poursuivre et s'intensifier les moyens
les moyens pour la police la gendarmerie
la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure les moyens pour
l'administration pénitentiaire parce que
l'on sait que la radicalisation
s'effectue aussi en milieu pénitencière
et que beaucoup de ceux qui parmi les
délinquants de droits commun sont
incarcérés rencontre parfois l'islamisme
radical en prison et par
conséquent sort avec la tentation de
commettre d'autres crimes qui n'avait
pas nécessairement envisagé de commettre
et tout cela doit être mis en œuvre
comme a commencé à le faire avec
beaucoup de force de détermination la
garde des sauts de manière à ce que nous
puissions apporter la juste réponse les
moyen mais nous devons
aussi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs nous attaquer à ce qui relève
des insuffisances
ou des inadaptation de notre système
juridique je me souviens très bien des
débats que nous avons eu à l'occasion de
l'adoption de la Loi antiterroriste il y
a de cela 2 mois
seulement nous avons adopté deux lois
antiterroristes depuis le début du
quinquena une première portée par le
Premier ministre lorsqu'il était
ministre de l'intérieur une seconde
portée par moi il y a de cela simplement
quelques semaines puisque cette loi
étaéit adoptée au mois de novembre et je
me souviens des débats que nous avons eu
il ne faut d'ailleurs pas les revisiter
pour nous faire grief les uns aux autres
des positionnements que nous avons eu il
est normal en démocratie je n'en ai pas
été choqué au moment où les débats ont
eu lieu que l'on cherche constamment le
juste équilibre entre la nécessité de
renforcer la sécurité des Français et de
ne jamais porter atteinte à leur liberté
mais je me souviens que dans ce débat
lorsque j'ai insisté sur le rôle
déterminant joué par internet et sur la
nécessité de procéder à davantage de
régulation à davantage d'intervention
pour que les messages de haine qui s'y
déploient sans limite soient enfin
cantonnés il y a eu une discussion sur
la nécessité de trouver le bon équilibre
entre cette exigence de régulation et la
neutralité d'Internet et la liberté
d'expression permise sur la toile je me
souviens que lorsqu'il a été proposé
l'interdiction administrative de sortie
du territoire pour ceux dont on savait
qu'ils allaient s'engager dans des
opérations terroristes et dont on était
à juste titre convaincu qu'il reviendrai
habité par la le seul instinct de la
haine il y a eu des débats sur la
liberté d'aller et venir et je me
souviens que lorsque nous avons présenté
une disposition à travers l'article 15
de la loi qui permettait à mon ministère
de pouvoir conserver au-delà de 30 jours
le contenu des interceptions de sécurité
de manière à ce que nous puissions aller
au bout de l'exploitation
des renseignements dont nous avions
besoin il y a eu des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat qui ne
nous ont pas permis d'aller au bout de
cette disposition que j'avais présenté
de manière à ce que nous puissions
disposer de la totalité des éléments
dont nous avons besoin pour procéder à
la surveillance nécessaire de ce que
nous devons surveiller et bien je
propose que dans le contexte nouveau
résultant des événements qui vientent de
se produire nous ne mettions pas en
place des lois d'exception
qui serait comme une première victoire
des terroristes sur nous-mêmes sur la
démocratie mais que nous fassions en
sorte lucidement de regarder la réalité
de manière à ce que nous puissions nous
doter de tous les moyens qui nous
permettent de lutter efficacement contre
le terrorisme en prenant toutes les
mesures notamment à travers la loi sur
le renseignement qui permettent à nos
services de disposer des outils dont ils
ont besoin pour être dans l'efficacité
et dans l'efficience enfin
le troisème point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur la nécessité de
travailler sur les organisations et les
coopérations beaucoup des sujets que
nous avons devant nous dépendent de nous
dépendent de vous législateurs qui a les
devoir comme le gouvernement en
regardant la situation nouvelle à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés nous
allons devoir ensemble prendre nos
responsabilités mais beaucoup dépend
aussi d'un cadre qui associe d'autres
institutions et d'autres États je veux
parler notamment de tous les enjeux
européens sur lesquels nous devons nous
mobiliser et que nous avons de nouveau
mis sur le métier dimanche dernier en
rassemblant à Paris les ministres de
l'Intérieur non seulement de l'Union
européenne mais aussi ceux d'autres pays
grande puissan avec lesquels nous
travaillons étroitement pour essayer
d'être plus efficace en en terme de
renseignement et de tellement
démentantellement des grandes filières
du crime organisé et notamment des
grandes filières terroristes je veux
parler tout d'abord de ce qui doit être
fait pour démanteler de façon
volontariste tous ceux qui procèdeent au
trafic d'armes c'est un trafic
international qui va bien au-delà des
frontières de l'Europe qui mobilise des
organisations du
crime qui parfois ont une dimension mul
nationale et qui conduise des acteurs à
utiliser des sociétés écran des comptes
dans des paradis fiscaux pour alimenter
le
terrorisme il faut que nous soyons
capable par des actions plus puissantes
sur internet par des échanges plus
réguliers entre services de
renseignement de faire en sorte que nous
puissions être dotés des moyens qui nous
permettent de démanteler rapidement ces
filières organisées du crime notamment
dans le domaine du trafic d'armes nous
devons en ensite faire en sorte que les
trajets de tous ceux qui agissent dans
ces réseaux terroristes puissent
davantage
identifié pour que le système
d'information Schengen avec son
dispositif de signalement nous permette
à tout moment d'arrêter les trajets de
ceux qui peuvent commettre des crimes
dans nos états après avoir traversé
l'Europe en en commettant parfois dans
plusieurs états après avoir fait escale
dans plusieurs aéroports c'est la mise
en place du PNR et comme l'a fait le
premier ministre tout à l'heure devant
l'Assemblée nationale je veux profiter
de notre débat pour appeler du Sénat
l'ensemble des parlementaires européens
à bien comprendre que nous ne pourrons
pas réussir la lutte contre le
terrorisme si le PNR ne se met pas en
place rapidement et qu'il est
possible qu'il est possible de le faire
qu'il est possible de le faire sans
préjudice pour les libertés publiques
puisque la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne vient de prendre une position
sur la protection la durée de détention
des données qui peut permettre de
trouver cet équilibre entre davantage de
protection des données et le PNR qui
permettra davantage de sécurité au plan
européen nous devons
aussi faire évoluer le regard que nous
portons sur
Schengen faire en sorte que nous
puissions dans le cadre du code actuel
en l'interprétant intelligemment faire
en sorte que des contrôles plus régulier
plus systématique puisse se faire pour
des vols en provenance d'un certain
nombre de pays de manière à assurer une
plus grande efficacité des contrôles de
la police de de l'air et des frontières
dans les aéroports comme nous devons
accepter d'engager une réflexion au sein
de l'Union européenne permettant une
modification rapide du code Schengen
destinée non pas à remettre en cause la
liberté de circulation non pas destiné à
remettre en cause l'atout que représente
la liberté de circul en Europe mais
destiné à faire en sorte que celle-ci se
conjugue avec l'exigence de sécurité
dont nous avons besoin nous avons besoin
de plus de coopération européenne nous
avons besoin de plus de coopération
internationale nous avons un agenda dont
vous voyez Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénateur qu'il est riche qui nous engage
et je voudrais conclure ce propos en
vous indiquant comme l'a fait le premier
ministre tout à l'heure devant les
députés que le gouvernement est
déterminé à faire ce travail avec vous
des s seront élaborées rapidement parce
que nous devons être dans le mouvement
dans l'efficacité dans la rapidité de la
réaction mais ces réflexions rapides
seront partagées avec vous parce que
nous voulons dans l'unité nationale
faire en sorte que la lutte contre le
terrorisme permette d'adopter les
meilleures dispositions dans le
consensus le plus large enfin je
voudrais conclure en vous disant aussi
que tout ce que nous allons faire
ensemble doit être inspiré par tout ce
que vous avez dit et qui qui nous
rassemble c'est-à-dire la volonté de
faire en sorte que dans la République la
laïcité qui permet à la République
d'accueillir en son sein tous ses
enfants le respect des valeurs de
liberté de tolérance et de respect de
l'autre même s'il est différent de nous
continue à l'emporter et à prévaloir
face à toutes les formes de terrorisme
et d'intolérance car ce qui a révélé la
manifestation de dimanche et ce que
révèle l'unité qui préside à notre
action c'est l'amour que nous avons de
la République de ses valeurs et c'est
cet amour qui nous donne de la force
face aux attaques des
terroristes
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre madame
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues pour cet hommage aux victimes
des attaques terroristes mais aussi par
ce partage des interrogations qui nous
sont posées par ces drames monsieur le
ministre le Sénat vous le savez est
disponible vigilant engagé mes chers
collègues je vais suspendre quelques
secondes pour que nous ordion l'ordre du
jour qui est une demande du gouvernement
d'autorisation de prolongation de
l'intervention de nos forces armées en
Irak merci mes chers collègues je
suspends quelques
secondes voilà donc pour cet hommage du
Sénat aux victimes des attentats de la
semaine dernière vous avez pu l'entendre
le ministre de l'Intérieur Bernard
casenov qui s'est exprimé à la suite des
différents présidents des groupes
politique du Sénat Bernard casne qui a
parlé plus d'une demi-heure à la tribune
du Sénat sans note il n'avait pas de
discours devant les yeux il a tenu à
répondre d'abord à l'émotion hein des
sénateurs qui s'est fait sentir pendant
cet hommage et puis à répondre également
et bien aux demandes à la fois des
politiques mais également des citoyens
quand on au renforcement peut-être des
moyens pour lutter contre le terrorisme
en France Bernard casenu qui était assez
ému en ce début but de séance il
l'arrivée de l'Assemblée nationale où un
hommage aussi très fort très poignant a
été rendu par l'ensemble des députés cet
après-midi aux victimes des des
attentats avec en conclusion un discours
très fort on peut le dire du Premier
ministre manuel Vals qui a été applaudi
voire même ovationné à plusieurs
reprises à l'Assemblée lors de son
discours par les députés de tous les
bords politiques gauche et droit
confondu qui se sont donc levés à
plusieurs reprises pour applaudir le
Premier ministre man manuel Vals qui a
d'ailleurs tenu à rendre un hommage
appuyé à son ministre de l'Intérieur
Bernard casenu qui est apparu très ému
presque en larme face à cet hommage de
Manuel Vals euh voilà donc pour
reprendre aussi quelques éléments
annoncés et avancés cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale par le Premier
ministre et sur lesquels le ministre de
l'Intérieur vient de revenir dans son
discours devant les sénateurs et bien le
Premier ministre invite Bernard
casazenuve à faire dans les 8 jours une
série de propositions le ministre de
l'Intérieur va donc devoir présenter au
président de la République et au Premier
ministre une série de propositions parmi
lesquelles certaines seront retenues et
présentées à la fois aux parlementaires
et aux Français manuel Vals qui a tenu à
souligner à plusieurs reprises dans son
discours à l'Assemblée nationale cet
après-midi et bien qu'il y aura un avant
et un après 11 janvier 2015 alors parmi
les mesures qui ont été avancé cet
après-midi par le Premier ministre à
l'Assemblée nationale et des mesures qui
ont été mentionnées à l'instant par
Bernard casneuve au Sénat et bien il y a
bien sûr le renforcement des mesures
dans les prisons est-ce qu'il va falloir
ou non isoler et bien les détenus
djihadistes est-ce qu'il va falloir
également renforcer les mesures de
surveillance sur la toile sur Internet
et bien on va voir tout ça alors
Monsieur Cambon le sénateur Cambon qui
fait partie de la commission des
affaires étrangères du Sénat est avec
nous bonjour Merci d'être à nos côtés
pour une après-midi dommage au Parlement
le Parlement qui a tenu dans son
ensemble Assemblée nationale et Sénat a
bouleversé son ordre du jour je sais pas
si vous avez pu suivre à l'Assemblée
nationale le discours du premier
ministre qui a été très fort tout à
l'heure il a été vionné par les députés
de droite hein comme comme de gauche et
puis le ministre de l'Intérieur à
l'instant c'était important
pour le Parlement de marquer aussi de
rendre hommage aux victimes des
attentats c'était un moment
particulièrement important un moment
émouvant il est assez rare de voir la
Marseillaise anentoné au sein même de
l'hémicycle je pense que c'est un un
souvenir terrible mais lourd de sens que
nous retiendrons je crois que nous avons
partagé les uns et les autres la
sincérité du gouvernement d'abord dans
l'hommage qui a été adressé aux
policiers et aux victimes qui sont
tombées et puis bien sûr le ministre de
l'Intérieur ur a tracer des perspectives
car maintenant va commencer le temps du
décryptage de ce drame et des solutions
qu'il va falloir mettre en œuvre et donc
le gouvernement tend la main au
Parlement pour faire en sorte
qu'ensemble nous travaillons jusqu'au
fond et on nous a été incité à aller
dans le détail il vaut aller vite he
manuel Vals est-ce qu'il a raison
d'aller vite il faut aller vite mais il
faut aussi prendre le temps pour ne pas
laisser de côté un certain nombre de
points nous aurons l'occasion lors des
questions de jeudi de soulever quelques
élément qui nous semble encore dans
l'ombre cela étant je pense que l'Union
nationale demeure maintenant le travail
des parlementaires est d'accompagner le
gouvernement pour que ce drame ne se
reproduise plus merci beaucoup Christian
Cambon d'avoir été à nos côtés on va
maintenant accueillir le président du
groupe socialiste au Sénat Didier
Guillaume Didier Guillaume bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct tous les
journaux titré ce matin en une et
maintenant j'ai envie de vous poser la
même question et maintenant qu'est-ce
qui va se passer est-ce qu'il faut aller
vite comme le souhaite sans doute le
premier ministre prend des mesures il y
a deux choses il ne faut pas que
l'esprit du 11 janvier retombe il faut
absolument que la France continue à être
assemblée que l'unité nationale soit là
que nous défendions les valeurs de la
République les valeurs de de laïcité
liberté d'égalité ve dire la droite et
la gauche travailler main dans la main
absument si nous avons la même
conception de la société nous devons
continuer dans cette direction il y aura
des débats politiques il y aura des
confrontations mais sur les sujets sur
les valeurs fondamentales nous pouvons
être ensemble il y a pas 4 millions dans
la rue pour rien et puis et maintenant
mais il faut aller plus loin il faut
prendre des mesures des mesures fortes
nous l'avons dit tout à l'heure dans le
débat les socialistes ne sont pas
favorables à un patriote acte à la à la
française nous ne sommes pas favorables
à des lois d'exception elles n'ont rien
de bien nous ne sommes pas favorables à
des lois liberticides mais nous sommes
favorables à des lois exceptionnelles
des lois qui vont loin des lois qui
doivent permettre de mener les est la
différence Guillaume entre des lois
exceptionn la liber la LI la liberté
c'est sacré et donc la liberté elle est
pour tout le monde les droits et les
devoirs ils sont pour tout le monde mais
par contre des lois exceptionnelles qui
vont permettre de mener plus vite les
enquêtes qui vont permettre d'avoir des
moyens aujourd'hui donc exceptionnel
dans le sens limité dans le temps oui
limité dans le temps enfin on peut pas
donner de réponse aujourd'hui il faut en
tout cas que nous répondions à une
grande inquiétude de nos concitoyens
sommes-nous en sécurité oui ou non la
sécurité est quelque chose que nos
concitoyens demandent et ont besoin et
ben il faut qu'ils a le sentiment qu'ils
sont en sécurité il faut qu'il ait le
sentiment que le gouvernement que le
Parlement met en place des règles des
loi qui va améliorer leur sécurité il
faut aller traquer la loi la loi9 qui
vient d'être adoptée par le Parlement à
la fin de l'année 2014 est excellente
pas mais bien sûr que non on s'aperçoit
on sait qu'elle ne suffit pas et le
ministre dit l'a dit lui-même quand il
s'agit de prendre des mesures un peu
plus fortes pour aller les cuillir à
l'étranger ben certains vous allez faire
remonter des propositions au Premier
ministre oui il faut je crois à la fois
pas d'angélisme et pas le tout
sécuritaire nous avons un pays de
liberté c'est la France c'est le pays
des Lumières la ligne de CR va être
difficile justement à nous à nous de le
trouver afin que tout simplement des des
des lois des règles beaucoup plus dures
qu'elles ne sont aujourd'hui puisse
aller directement dans ce sens-l mais en
même temps il faut l'éducation il faut
la culture il faut faire comprendre que
l'appartenance à la nation est
essentielle il faut faire comprendre que
la laïcité elle est essentielle il faut
faire comprendre que la France n'est pas
en guerre contre l'islam mais que la
France est en guerre contre les
terroristes les djihadistes l'islamisme
ce n'est pas la même chose
l'appartenance à la nation elle doit
être très forte et le soufflet du du 11
janvier si nous ne voulons pas qu'il
retombe simplement pour dire à tout le
monde nous sommes touses et tous toutes
et tous des enfants de la République des
enfants de la nation française nous
avons un hymne national nous avons des
valeurs communes ch tout à l'heure dans
lesicycl du C
is vous l'entendiez c'est la première
fois que j'ai vu ça une une à
l'Assemblée nationale c'était la
première fois cet après-midi depuis 1918
j'imagine que c'est la même chose ici au
sén une minute de silence dans un
silence glacial moi j'avais les les
poils qui se dressaient sur sur les bras
et une Marseillaise entonnée à l'unisson
l'unisson de la République l'unition de
la nation pas de naïveté il y a des
différences entre la droite et la gauche
mais là-dessus nous devons nous
retrouver retrouvons-nous dans l'intérêt
du pays dernière question Didier
Guillaume avant de rejoindre l'émicycle
s'exprime en ce moment Laurent Fabius le
président du Sénat Gérard Larché ne
souhaite pas une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur les attentats de de la
semaine dernière vous le regrettez il
estime qu'il y a déjà une commission
d'enquête c'est vrai qu'il travaille he
depuis le mois d'octobre ici au Sénat
sur les filières djihadistes et qu'elle
a suffisamment avancé dans son travail
oui il y a la commission d'enquête du
Sénat et celle de l'Assemblée sur le
djihadisme mais il me semble que
justement dans le cadre de cette unité
nationale une mission globale
transpartisane Assemblée nationale et
Sénat ser un peu plus de force me
semble-t-il sachant que des
parlementaires peuvent pas enquêter
quand il y a une action judiciaire bien
sûr mais il y a toujours la possibilité
de de donner des S enfin nous verrons
bien tout cela n'est pas grave
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est que le
chef de l'État dans un grand discours à
la nation s'adressant à la nation donne
ses orientations ce qu'il faut c'est que
le premier ministre comme il l'a fait
cet après-midi donne les directions sur
lesquelles nous allons travailler merci
beaucoup Didier et Guillaume d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions on va
donner le micro à Pierre Laurent je vois
qu'il est juste derrière vous et qu'il
attend donc avant de rejoindre Laurent
Fabius dans l'hémicycle on va peut-être
avoir le sentiment de de Pierre Laurent
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur Public Sénat qu'avez-vous ressenti
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
à la fois sur l'émotion lors de cet
hommage
ouais d'une part il y avait
effectivement à nouveau un très grand
moment d'émotion national et je pense
que c'est c'est extrêmement légitime et
l'hommage national était nécessaire pour
cette rentrée et puis euh dans le
discours du ministre de l'Intérieur il y
a euh une partie seulement des questions
qui sont abordées la question de la
sécurité manquit selon vous bien comme
l'a rappelé la présidente de notre
groupe il y a dans Ilan Assassi dans ce
que on dit les
Français tout au long de ces derniers
jours et dans les marches il y a
l'exigence de de créer à nouveau les
conditions d'un véritable vivre ensemble
et ça passe aussi par des moyens par
exemple pour les services publicque pour
l'école dont on voit bien qu'elle est
aussi très
concern l'éducation rencontre en ce
moment tous les acteurs autour de
l'enseignement de l'école va sans doute
annoncer des mesures mais je l'espère
parce que l'école a besoin de moyens le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé des
moyens supplémentaires pour la police ce
qui montre bien que les réductions de
services publics ont aussi des
conséquences parfois fâcheus mais il
faut d'autres moyens il faut des moyens
pour les collectivités locales il en
faut pour l'école il en faut pour les
services publics d'une manière générale
il en faut pour la justice il faut
réfléchir à beaucoup de questions qui
ont été posées par différentes vention
des groupes et notamment le nôtre donc
c'est la fin d'unité nationale chacun va
c'est maintenant c'est non maintenant
c'est un débat exigeant et nous allons
discuter chacune des mesures les mesures
qui doivent avancer celles qui nous
conviennent celles qui sont discutables
et tout ça va avancer normalement le
débat démocratique et politique reprend
avec exigence pour répondre à tout ce
qu' ce que veulent les Français ce que
souhaitent les Français la sécurité dans
la justice très bien ben écoutez merci
beaucoup Pierre Laurent d'avoir été en
direct à notre mic on va repartir
maintenant dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
puisqu a débuté la séance un débat
autour de l'intervention de la France en
Irak c'est un demande c'est un débat à
la demande du gouvernement donc on va
écouter Laurent Fabius et puis on
reviendra pour d'autres réactions ici en
direct de la salle des conférences du
sén ce rapport de force l'organisation
terroriste conserve en effet l'essentiel
de son potentiel militaire elle a adapté
ses modes d'action elle a consolidé un
certain nombre de ses positions
défensives et vous avez la carte l'es
la menace qu'elle fait peser en
particulier à l'ouest de Bagdad demeure
préoccupante notre dispositif lui il est
monté progressivement en
puissance la représentation nationale
est informée en toute transparence après
une première phase de déploiement le
président de la République a décidé
d'adapter nos moyens à l'évolution de la
situation des forces
irakiennes aujourd'hui nous avons 15
avions de combat à la fois rafale et
Mirage 2000 qui sont engagés dans les
opérations ils interviennent depuis les
Émirats et depuis la Jordanie nous
déployons aussi des moyens de soutien en
ravitaillement en vol en détection et en
collecte de
renseignements depuis la mi-sepembre nos
avions ont réalisé un peu plus de 300
missions elles ont effectué notamment 34
frappes contre les infrastructures des
véhicules des postes de combat ces
opérations aériennes ont contribué à
affaiblir le potentiel des terroristes
et permis d'obtenir des renseignements
en particulier sur les combattants venus
de
l'étranger en plus de ces opération
aérienne nous participons avec d'autres
pays partenaires à la fourniture
d'armement ainsi qu'au Conseil et à la
formation des combattants
kurdes au total donc et je donne cette
précision parce que parfois il y a une
certaine confusion dans les chiffres
c'est une centaine de formateurs que
nous avons sur place sur place même
mais dans les pays circomvoisins nous
avons un dispositif qui s'élève à un
millier de personnes et donc nous sommes
après les États-Unis un des pays qui est
les plus impliqués dans la coalition
notre dispositif va continuer d'évoluer
des militaires français vont participer
à des missions de formation pour l'armée
irakienne et il y a le groupe aéronaval
avec le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle
qui fait sa tournée annuelle qui qui
doit aller vers l'Inde et qui peut
l'amener à être présent dans le golf
arabopersique maintenant un point sur
lequel je pense nous sommes tous
d'accord et qui est très important à
toujours rappeler c'est que bien
évidemment nous avons décidé parce que
c'était nécessaire d'intervenir et
d'intervenir par nos moyens aériens mais
nous le savons tous la stabilité l'IRAC
et celle de la région ne peuvent pas
être obtenu uniquement par des moyens
militaires et donc nous avons besoin
d'une stratégie politique d'ensemble qui
est indispensable et la remarque que je
fais elle vaut pour à peu près tous les
conflits c'est une des grandes leçons de
conflit précédent en Irak d'abord où
l'action sur le terrain de la coalition
ne peut venir qu'en appui d'un processus
politique au cours des derniers mois la
situation politique s'est stabilisé le
nouveau Premier ministre qui est
monsieur alabadi a constitué un
gouvernement ouvert à toutes les
composantes politiques et ethniques et
c'est maintenant un immense travail de
reconstruction qui a commencé et
seulement commencé d'être entrepris les
chantiers sont considérables il y a les
réforme et la modernisation de la parée
de sécurité il y a la lutte contre la
corruption il y a la mise en place c'est
très important d'un nouveau cadre
fédéral qui garantisse le maintien de
l'unité de l'Irak ce qu'on appelle dans
un
anglicisme une pratique inclusive du
gouvernement et il faut permettre en
même temps la représentation équitable
des différentes communautés et bien sûr
la reconstruction économique la France
je le dis est au côté du nouveau
gouvernement iraakien pour la mise en
œuvre de ce programme et c'est ce
message de tien que le Président de la
République a adressé au Premier ministre
iraakien lorsque nous l'avons reçu au
mois de décembre dernier
et c'est le sens de l'action que je mène
qui est une action diplomatique qui doit
être menée en parallèle avec l'action
proprement militaire la France comme
vous le savez concentre son action sur
le théâtre iraakien nous avons fait le
choix c'est un choix certains le
discutent mais nous le maintenons de ne
pas mener de frappes aériennes en Syrie
ça ne veut pas dire du tout qu'il ne
faille rien faire en Syrie et nous
agissons en particulier en soutenant
fortement l'opposition modérée c'est
aussi le choix de nos partenaires
européens à l'exception de nos amis
britannique bien sûr la situation de
certaines villes assiégées je pense à
cobané je pense à Halep ne laisse de
même que les autres situations aucun
d'entre nous indifférent et nous sommes
actifs mais notre ligne est la même et
Premier ministre tout à l'heure à
l'Assemblée nationale laa résumé par une
formule qui disait ni Bachar ni daesh il
faut préciser de cette formule il n'est
évidemment pas question de soutenir si
peu que ce soit le groupe terroriste
daesh il faut combattre mais ce serait
une illusion de croire que on arriverait
à combattre durablement daesh si l'autre
terme de l'alternative proposée était de
maintenir éternellement au pouvoir
monsieur Bachar alhassad car si le choix
à la population n'est offert qu'entre
d'un côté des terroristes et de
l'autre un groupe ou plutôt un pouvoir
qui a facilité le terrorisme
rappelez-vous que ces terroristes sont
pour une part sortis des prisons et ont
été sortis par le dictateur euh ce
serait l'espèce de à la fois de combat
mais en même temps d'épalement per
Manent entre les deux entendons-nous
bien il faut mener la lutte il faut
avoir une perspective politique et je
suis clair et nous travaillons sur ce
point avec d'autres à la fois les
Nations Unies bien sûr à la fois avec
les Russes et avec d'autres pays
l'objectif c'est d'arriver même si c'est
extraordinairement difficile à trouver
une solution politique qui doit être
composé à la fois de certains éléments
du régime on ne peut
pas passer autrement faut de quoi tous
les piliers de l'État s'effondreraient
et et nous aurions la situation
irakienne d'avant et d'autre part des
éléments de coalition qu'on appelle
modéré pour que toutes les communautés
soient représentées que ce soient les
alawites que ce soient les chrétiens que
soi les autres communautés pour si c'est
possible une Syrie qui soit unie où
chacun soit respecté et donc ne nous
trompons pas ce débat bien sûr il est
sur l'aspect militaire mais notre
objectif reste politique et en Syrie
nous affichons clairement la couleur qui
n'est absolument pas de nous intéresser
qui n'est absolument pas d'être naïf
personne d'entre nous ne l''est mais qui
est de permettre une solution très
difficile puisque Genève d' a échoué
Genève 2 a échoué mais nous continuer
nous continuons avec nos partenaires à
travailler dans cette direction qui
nécessite à la fois une approche
politique et une approche militaire je
voulais être un peu plus précis
là-dessus parce que j'entends des
approximations parfois qui sont
développées et une tendance que je sens
ici ou là à dire mais comme dash ce sont
des terroristes et ce sont des
terroristes alors il faut oublier euh
les reproches que nous pouvons faire à
Monsieur Bachar al-Assad et se
précipiter pour étreindre monsieur
Bachar al-Assad la réalité vous le
comprenez est évidemment beaucoup plus
complexe et c'est à cette complexité
quand en répondre la position de la
France ce choix n'est absolument pas
synonyme d'immobilisme nous soutenons
l'opposition syrienne qui combat les
groupes djihadistes nous tenons prêt au
côté nos partenaires à mener des actions
renforcées de formation et d'équipement
en Syrie comme en Irak nous pensons
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres termes de
l'alternative qu'une solution politique
qui passe par une transition avec toutes
les forces qui veulent reconstruire une
nouvelle Syrie mais qui ne pourra pas
durablement inclure monsieur Bachar
alAssad et nous devons travailler en ce
sens avec les Nations Unies avec nos
partenaires américains avec les États
voisins mais aussi avec les Russes agir
c'est aussi continuer à nous mobiliser
sur le plan humanitaire c'est un travail
considérable
immense les pays de la région je pense à
la Turquie je pense au Liban je pense à
la Jordanie à d'autres encore cons sent
des sacrifices énormes pour accueillir
des réfugiés syriens vous avez reçu
comme moi des amis libanais qui viennent
décrire la situation euh l'un d'entre
eux me disait que si nous avions en
France l'équivalent en proportion de ce
que représentent les réfugiés syriens
pour eux nous aurions près de 20
millions de personnes imaginez ce que ça
signifie d'un point de vue économique
d'un point de vue politique d'un point
de vue social c'est une situation
évidemment épouvantable notre devoir est
d'assister ces populations ce sont donc
des centaines de tonnes d'aide
humanitaire que nous avons déjà livré on
dira ce sont des chiffres importants ils
sont dirisoires par rapport aux
nécessités je remercie le Sénat quel que
soit d'ailleurs les groupes concernés
d'être extrêmement actifs et attentifs
dans cette direction tout comme nous
continuerons aussi à accueillir en
France au titre de l'asile des familles
syriennes et irakiennes appartenant aux
minorités pour chasser c'est à l'honneur
de la France alors pourquoi faut-il
poursuivre et bien les interventions
militaires comme les solutions
politiques ne peuvent malheureusement
pas donner de résultat immédiat et il
faut être lucide dans ce domaine comme
dans celui très lié que tout à l'heure
notre ami Caseneuve abordé à cette
tribune réduire daesh est un objectif
que nous devons atteindre mais qui
prendra du temps nous sommes donc
engagés dans la durée abandonner
aujourd'hui quitter nos partenaires
serait plus qu'un échec ce serait
abandonneré l'Irak et ses populations
face aux terroristes et des assassin
dont l'ambition territoriale n'a aucune
limite et là encore évitons ce qui
peut-être un réflexe compris parfois
chez certains compatriotes qui
n'auraient pas vu l'ensemble du problème
je veux rappeler que le drame de
Toulouse que chacun d'entre vous a à
l'esprit avec les attentats terroristes
s'est produit à un moment où la France
n'était présente ni au Mali ni en Irak
et donc il faut faire très attention à
tout cela c'est malheureusement un
phénomène international par rapport
auquel il faut que nous soyons d'une
grande détermination dash a un programme
exporter sa terreur partout répandre le
crime dans le monde menacer nos sociétés
aujourd'hui nous voyons les conséquences
de ce plan le Liban fragilisé par le
poids des réfugiés la Jordan la Turquie
suissant de point po le contrecoup de la
crise syrienne et parce que les
terroristes continuent de tuer de
massacrer d'exterminer nous devons pour
notre part poursuivre notre tâche et
parce que le terrorisme continue de
menacer l'équilibre de la région et de
déstabiliser du même coup les pays
voisins et le nôtre nous devons
poursuivre notre mission parce que dash
continue de vouloir recruter former des
terroristes dont des Européens et des
Français pour nous frapper pour semer la
terreur et la destruction sur notre sol
nous devons aussi poursuivre notre
stratégie et parce que la mission n'est
pas terminée parce que nous ne devons
abandonner ni nos partenaires ni les
Irakiens nous devons là aussi poursuivre
notre action nous poursuivrons aussi au
Sahel nos inquiétudes se tournent vers
la Libye vous le savez espace dont les
déserts immense et non contrôlé du Sud
deviennent un nouveau repère pour le
terrorisme djihadiste nos inquiétudes se
tournent aussi vers la région du bassin
du lac Tchad où prospère dangereusement
la secte Boko Haram qui encore tout
derniers jours semme la terreur avec des
crimes effrayant commis non seulement au
Nigéria mais au Cameroun et dans les
pays voisins et là encore je veux saluer
nos soldats parce que dans beaucoup des
régs que j'ai cité ils sont présents et
accomplissent en notre nom et au nom de
l'humanité un travail absolument
magnifique
euh nous avons parlé tous ces jours-ci
vous avez abordé tout à l'heure ensemble
la question gravissime du
terroriste monsieur
casazenu a bien décrit la
situation le Premier ministre l'abordait
dans son propos tout à l'heure vous
connaissez les chiffres nous avons à ce
jour près de 400 individus qu'il soi
français ou résidents français qui
combattent sur place et nous en avons 67
qui sont récemment morts au cours des
combats certains de nos compatriotes
sont malheureusement impliqué dans les
atrocités commises par
daesh certains par participe également à
la propagande appelle à commettre des
attaques sur notre territoire et face à
tout cela il nous faut agir avec
beaucoup de sang-froid beaucoup de
discernement mais aussi beaucoup de
détermination les moyens on les a évoqué
tout à l'heure et vous aurez l'occasion
d'en reparler au cours des prochaines
semaines nous entendons les adapter à la
mesure de l'évolution de la menace mais
nous savons que
ce qui compa au-delà de ces moyens c'est
la détermination profonde de la
population
française la
démocratie ne combat jamais aussi
efficacement le terrorisme qu'en
promouvant nos valeurs qui s'appellent
bien sûr la liberté l'égalité et on l'a
rappelé à juste titre la
laïcité ce que nous venons de vivre est
une invitation à sursaut il y a une
épreuve
elle doit nous rendre encore plus fort
et puisque c'est le domaine qui m imp
parti je dois vous dire sortant un
instant de mon sujet mais j'en suis sûr
rencontrant
votre perception à tous que en voyant
dimanche à nos côtés le quart des
dirigeants de la planète je dis bien le
cas être
rassemblé autour des plus hautes
autorités
françaises pour
dire tout simplement que la France c'est
la patrie des libertés et que quand on
touche aux libertés de la France on
touche aux libertés de l'ensemble des
pays je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui a été ressenti profondément par
chacune et chacun de vous et assurément
par T nos compatriotes j'ajoute qu' est
un grand pays et vous en donnez
l'illustration cette aprèm dit c'est
d'être un pays uni et c'est cela aussi
la réponse que nous devons apporter au
terrorisme l'unité de la République ce
qui vous est demandé ce soir c'est
puisque le choix pour les raisons que
j'ai dites a été fait d'engager des
soldats français à l'extérieur de nos
frontières qui n'est jamais une décision
qui se prend à la
légère puisque derrière cette décision
ce sont des femmes et des hommes qui
s'exposent mais en même temps qui
s'exposent pour nous
protéger ce qui vous est demandé c'est
de juger avec nous que cette décision
j'allais dire malheureusement est
nécessaire car la guerre contre le
terrorisme c'est un combat de longue
haleine c'est la raison pour laquelle je
demande à votre assemblée au nom du
Gouvernement de la République de
permettre à la France d'agir
conformément à ses valeurs et à ses
intérêts je vous demande d'autoriser nos
armées à poursuivre les opérations en
Irak et au service de ce à quoi nous
croyons ce qui fait l'unité de la France
au service tout simplement de la
démocratie et de la liberté
merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
j'indique au Sédat que la Conférence des
Présidents a fixé à raison d'un orateur
par groupe à 15 minutes le temps
attribué au groupe PP au groupe
socialiste et à 10 minutes le temps
attribué aux autres groupes les
sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe disposant de 5 minutes je
rappelle que les interventions des
orateurs vaudront explication de
vote dans la suite du débat la parole
est aux orateurs des groupes et tout
d'abord notre collègue Robert U pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique et
social et européen vous avez la
parole monsieur président monsieur le
ministre messieurs les ministres
euh mes chers collègues le débat sur la
prolongation de l'opération Chamal en
Irak intervient
seulement quelques jours après les
attentats terroristes tragiques qui ont
coûté la vie à 17 personnes et blessé
plusieurs autres de nos concitoyens nous
venons d'en
parler ce drame est d'abord celui de de
famille brutalement
endeuillé de familles vers lesquelles
j'adresse ici solennellement toutes nos
pensées ainsi que celle de mes collègues
du groupe RDSE et je rejoins bien
évidemment les propos du président mard
qui vient de s'exprimer au nom de notre
groupe dans le débat précédent consacré
précisément à ces attaques terroristes
qu'il me soit permis de souligner une
nouvelle fois mes chers collègues que
dimanche la France a offert au monde et
elle-même l'image de l'unité de la
solidarité et de la
détermination la mobilisation massive
d'une grande dignité de millions de
Français a montré une capacité certaine
à la résilience bien entendu après le
temps de l'émotion nous devons passer le
minist de l'intérieur l'évoqué tout à
l'heure autant de la réflexion et de
l'action mais ce n'est pas euh je le
sais bien l'objet de ce débat maintenant
même même s'il n'est pas sans lien avec
ce que nous avons connu ces derniers
jours sur le territoirees
National monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est aussi bien sûr un combat que nous
devons mener à l'extérieur de nos
frontières en soutien aux États
fragilisés par les groupes djidaïstes et
et terroristes le dernier livre blanc
sur la défense le rappelait clairement
la possibilité que des territoires je
cite échappe durablement au contrôle
d'un État est un risque stratégique de
première importance pour l'Europe nous y
sommes aussi au regard de la menace que
représente l'établissement d'un califat
dirigé par le groupe terroriste Dah le
président de la République a décidé de
lancer l'opération mal en septembre
2014 l'attachement profond au respect
des droits de l'homme que chacun d'entre
nous peut avoir ici impose des
responsabilités lorsque ces droits sont
bafoués en répondant à la demande
officielle des autorités irakiennes la
France a tenu son rôle les atrocités
commises contre des minorités
religieuses et ethniqu en particulier
contre les femmes par les judaïstes de
Dah dans leur progression jusqu'à Mossou
cétait évoqué tout à l'heure ainsi que
l'assassinat barbare de plusieurs
autages occidentaux ont dicté la
réaction de la communauté internationale
comme je l'ai souligné lors du débat qui
s'est tenu le 24 septembre dernier les
visés
expansionnistes d'un certain nombre dans
la région et et la volonté farouche de
réussir là où Ben Laden a échoué
nécessitait de une réponse urgente
d'urgence à la hauteur sans contester le
principe de l'engagement d'une coalition
internationale voilà on interrons
quelques instants cette séance du Sénat
autour de la prolongation de
l'intervention militaire française en
Irak pour écouter le ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard casazenuf qui était
qui était il y a juste quelques instants
à nos côtés il revenait sur l'émotion au
Parlement aujourd'hui on écoute Bernard
casenuve Bernard casenuve bonjour merci
nous accorder quelques instants à votre
sortie de l'hémicycle du Sénat on vous a
vu bien sûr très ému aujourd'hui à la
fois dans l'émicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale et dans celui du Sénat c'est
une journée particulière au Parlement
aujourd'hui oui c'est une journée
particulière d'abord parce que nous
sommes dans le recueillement nous sommes
encore dans l'émotion dans le
recueillement dans le respect de la
mémoire de ceux qui sont tombés à
l'occasion de ces terribles
attentats les journalistes qui incarnent
la liberté d'expression les policiers
qui incarnent le droit l'État de droit
les Juifs de France que qui n'ont pas
avoir peur dont nous ne voulons plus
qu'ils aient peur et que la République a
voulu serrer dans ses bras les musulmans
de France don nous ne voulons pas comme
l'a dit le Premier ministre à juste
titre tout à l'heure avec beaucoup de
force et des mots magnifiques ilils
aient honte parce que l'islamisme
radical le dévoiement de l'islam dans la
violence n'est pas l'islam et n'est pas
la communauté musulmane de France et
puis par ailleurs moi j'ai à l'esprit
très présent encore le souvenir du
regard des policiers après que leurs
camarad étaient tombé et aussi après
qu'ils sont intervenus avec un
courage qui forcera jusqu'à mon dernier
souffle mon admiration vous attendez
maintenant des parlementaires qui vous
fassent remonter des propositions dans
le lot de de proposition vous allez
présenter au Premier ministre sous une
huitaine de jours comme ilourd nous
souhaitons le Premier ministre et
gouvernement le président de la
République c'est que dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme nous soyons
ensemble et par
conséquent il faut beaucoup de
gouvernements on été affrontés au
terrorisme il faut que nous soyons
capable de regarder la réalité en face
d'unir nos forces d'entendre toutes les
propositions personne comm bien entendu
moi j'ai entendu toutes les propositions
venant de tous les bancs de la
représentation nationale hier place
beauovau je recevrai d'ailleurs tous les
anciens ministres de l'Intérieur au
cours des prochains jours pour
recueillir également leur
expérience leur appréciation leur
sentiments et puis j'essaiai au moment
où j'adresse des propositions au Premier
ministre au président de la République
et d'ici quelques jours d'avoir fait la
synthèse de tout ce qui est pertinent il
faut pas avoir d'amour propre d'auteur
dans le contexte il faut avoir la
volonté d'être efficace et la volonté
d'être efficace c'est face à l'épreuve
beaucoup de mobilisation beaucoup de
concentration mais aussi beaucoup
d'humilité dernière question Bernard
casna vous avez été sur tous les fronts
ces derniers jours ça d être un grand
réconfort quand même pour vous de vous
faire applaudir à la fois à l'Assemblée
et au Sénat par tous les bancs gauche
droite confondu oui bien entendu ça m'a
beaucoup ému parce que euh ça a été des
moments extrêmement durs et en même
temps c'est aussi une nécessité pour moi
de prendre de la force dans la
représentation nationale pour continuer
parce que moi je suis
concentré sur la suite il y a des
enquêtes qui se poursuivent il y a des
personnes à mettre hors d'état de nuire
il y a la volonté d'assurer la sécurité
des Français il y a des initiatives
européennes et internationales à prendre
et donc euh moi je dois agir sans trêve
ni pause il n'y a pas de trêve de pause
dans le combat contre le terrorisme pour
les ministres qui sont en charge de ce
combat très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre d'avoir répondu à à nos
quelques questions à votre sortie de de
l'hémicycle on va rejoindre maintenant
l'émicy pour V invation voilà donc
Bernard casenuve qui était il y a
quelques instants sur notre antenne à
notre micro pour revenir sur l'émotion
au Parlement euh qui a rendu dans son
ensemble le Parlement l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat hommage aux
victimes des attentats euh de la semaine
dernière on va maintenant écouter la
réaction du président du groupe UMP ici
au Sénat Bruno rotaillot qui était
également il y a quelques minutes à
notre micro on
l'écoute Bruno rotillot bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct de cette
salle des conférences manuel Val dit
tout à l'heure à l'Assemblée nationale
il y aura un avant et un après 11
janvier 2015 en référence bien sûr aux
manifestations de ce dimanche vous êtes
d'accord avec lui et comment prolonger
cet état d'union nationale oui je suis
absolument d'accord avec lui par la
gravité par la réaction du du peuple
français aussi je pense que dimanche on
a vu que les Français étaient un peuple
peut-être l'avait-il oublié d'ailleurs
avec un socle un idéal commun un idéal
de valeur les valeurs qui ont été
attaqué la liberté d'expression vous
êtes journaliste vous savez de quoi je
parle et je pense qu'il y a quelque
chose de rassurant parce que finalement
la République dimanche s'est montré plus
forte que le terrorisme alors comment
prolonger ce consensus national ici au
Parlement est-ce qu'il va pas très vite
se fissurer autour des mesures qui qui
vont être prises pour renforcer
notamment la sécurité des Français
écoutez moi je pense qu'il faut que à la
fois le peuple de
France réalise bien que ce sont ces
valeursl qui font que nous sommes une
communauté nationale mais au-delà les
valeurs auxquelles on tient de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité ce sont aussi
des valeurs de la démocratie la
démocratie c'est en même temps le débat
il sera parfaitement naturel à un moment
ou à un autre qu'il y ait ce débat
politique parce que nous aurons sans
doute et c'est bien comme cela une
vision différente des problèmes il est
absolument nécessaire aujourd'hui parce
que les les Français veulent la vérité
ils exigent la sécurité et nous n'avons
pas le droit de leur refuser donc il
faudra réexaminer réévaluer l'ensemble
de notre arsenal Arsenal notamment en
termes législatifs mais aussi de de
sécurité c'est en même temps les moyens
d'intégration de l'assimilation c'est en
même temps un certain nombre de d'autres
questions qu'il va falloir étudier dans
le détail
est jusqu'à un patriote acte certains
l'UMP le le Souha on est français on
n'est pas américain donc moi je célèbre
je célèbre les valeurs voilà de la
République
françaiseement léis absolument en tout
cas il a une chose qui est claire c'est
qu'on peut pas avoir 17 morts sans qu'il
y ait eu des problèmes il y a eu des
problèmes il y a eu des échecs il faut
en tirer les conséquences en tirer les
leçons vous venez d'adopter une nouvelle
loi au Parlement la loi du ministre de
l'Intérieur Bernard casenuve au MOV oui
même temps dans ce texte il y avait eu
des amendements que nous avions proposé
qui ont été refusés par exemple
l'isolement dans les prisons parce qu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui i la prison qui
devrait être une sorte de bouclier pour
la société est souvent une forme de
radicalisation une forme de prosélitisme
bon c aménement avait été refusé il y en
a aussi d'autres je pense qu'on va
réexaminer y compris d'ailleurs avec le
ministre de intérieur je suis prêt à le
faire mais je pense que l'objectif c'est
pas l'unité nationale l'objectif c'est
la sécurité aussi des Français il est
parfaitement normal si on parle de
valeur de la République que les valeurs
de la démocratie du débat soi respecté
heureusement d'ailleurs il y avait
l'idée d'une commission d'enquête
commune au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale sur les attentats de de la
semaine dernière le président Larcher
l'a refusé pourquoi non il n'a pas
refusé tout simplement il nous semble
que les textes ne nous le permettent pas
ce qui est important c'est qu'il y a eu
deux commissions d'enquête l'une qui est
à l'Assemblée nationale et l'autre qui
est au Sénat celle qui est au Sénat a
commencé 3 mois plus tôt que celle qui
était à l'Assemblée nationale la
commission absolument la commission
d'enquête est quelque chose d'important
parce que elle a un pouvoir contraignant
par exemple lorsqu'elle auditionne
lorsqu'elle fait des auditions et bien
les gens qui l' auditionnent euh parle
sous serment c'est important donc nous
avons donc une deè commission d'qu SEM
pas nécessaire on va pas refaire des
machins machin on est en train de
travailler une partie de la commission é
il y a quelques jours en tur qu'on
aurait pu envisager une meilleure
coopération entre les deux commissions
d' celle du Sénat et celle de
l'Assemblée nationale ce que je
saision le président Larcher propose
aussi au président de l'Assemblée
national que les deux présidents du
Parlement puissent à calendrier régul
faire un certain nombre de points pour
coordonner les avancées le travail de de
ces deux commissions attention on a
commencé un travail on on a commencé
encore une fois ils étaient je crois un
certain nombre de sénateurs sénatrices
étaient sur la frontière turco-syrienne
il y a quelques jours ce ce travail-là
il faut vite le faire c'était la semaine
dernière absolument donc il y a aucun
sujet il faut pas qu'il y ait des
polémiques là-dessus l'important je vais
vous dire c'est la rapidité et c'est
l'efficacité et vous souhaitez que le
Parlement soit associé aux mesures qui
vont être prises comment pourrait-il ne
pas l'être bien entendu dans la loi il
faudra sans doute revisiter un certain
nombre de textes euh mais ça débordera
la loi ça débordera aussi la sécurité il
y a un certain nombre de questions vous
savez que dans des classes certains ont
refusé d'observer une m de silence sur
la toile un certain nombre de tweet de
messages sur Facebook ça nous interroge
gravement cette absolue radicalité h
donc là là aussi vous attend vous
attendez des mesures fortes de la part
de la ministre de l'Éducation nationale
il faut réféchir parce que ce genre de
chose
hé il temp Ty de mes très bien Ben
écoutezi qui vouserci merci beaucoup
Bruno rotillo d'être venu en direct sur
notre antenne on va repartir en séance
pour la suite du débat autour de
l'intervention française en Irak
justement merci voilà donc une interview
enregistrée il y a quelques secondes
effectivement comme je viens de l on
repart dans l'hémicycle du Sénat pour la
suite de ce débat autour de la
prolongation de l'intervention militaire
française en Irak c'est actuellement un
des deux sénateurs Front National qui
s'expriment Stéphane Ravier on poursuit
cette séance irien et CD au moyen d'une
quinzaine d'avion de combat et de deux
bâtiments de la Marine nationale le
porteavion Charles de Gaul doit quitté
ton cette semaine et vous avez annoncé
le 17 décembre dernier devant la
commission des affaires étrangères des
forces armées du Sénat l'envoi de 120
soldats français au côté des forces de
sécurité irakienne et curd cela fait de
nous le deuxème contributeur à la
coalition devant les Britanniques ces
mêmes britanniques qui en intervenant en
2003 au côté des États-Unis porte une
lourde responsabilité dans la
déstabilisation de cette région
toutefois le poids militaire de cette
coalition reste relativement mesuré et
ses forces n'arrivent toujours pas à
stopper l'armée djihadiste de DAEs nous
voterons donc pour la prolongation de
notre intervention mais nous pensons
qu'il faut aller plus loin si nous
voulons non seulement honorer notre rôle
multiséculaire de protecteur des
chrétiens d'Orient mais aussi tout
simplement protéger les Français en
France la priorité pour notre pays est
d'éliminer ce cancer de l'islamisme armé
et ces métastases qui s'étendent jusque
sur notre sol et de permettre ainsi aux
populations déplacées de revenir chez
ell vivre en paix je n'ignore pas que
les modalités d'intervention relèvent de
l'exécutif mais pour être efficace vous
allez devoir revenir sur certains de vos
choix qui ont eu des conséquences
gravissimes vous devez de toute urgence
cesser de dépouiller nos armées de leurs
moyens humains et financiers vous leur
demandez toujours plus avec toujours
moins de moyens non seulement en
opération extérieure mais aussi
désormais sur le territoire national
avec le déploiement de 10000 hommes sur
notre sol la France est aujourd'hui
notre premier théâtre d'opération vous
l'avez dit vous-même il s'agit d'une
véritable opération intérieure sans
précédent vous devez exiger de la
Turquie qu'elle soit enfin claire dans
son appui contre l'État islamique au
lieu de l'utiliser contre les Kurdes
vous devez tirer toutes les conséquences
de la continuité territoriale entre la
Syrie et l'Irak qui constitue un vaste
une vaste bande able où l'État islamique
prospère sur fond de trafic vous devez
enfin également reprendre un dialogue
soutenu avec le régime syrien non pas
pour le sanctifier ou l'absoudre mais
tout simplement pour réduire notre
ennemi premier qui est un ennemi commun
enfin ce dialogue impliquant les autres
grandes puissances comme les États-Unis
et la Russie doit prendre en compte les
spécificités régionales de grâce C son
de vouloir dupliquer nos propres
institutions et faisons enfin preuve de
réalisme dans des pays qui n'ont pas les
mêmes traditions ti que les nôtres il
est donc urgent et légitime de prolonger
notre intervention en Irak mais aussi
d'agir en Syrie et de monter en
puissance jusqu'à ce que cette région ne
soit plus un sanctuaire et un camp
d'entraînement géant pour ces dihadistes
qui nous ont si durement frappé dans
notre
chair la parole est maintenant notre
collègue Emie de
montessou monsieur le Président Berri
debas
pas le
dossier vous avez la parole mon cher
collègue merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président madamees messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
fumes totalement pris par
surprise comment près de 200000 km Carr
d'Irak et de Syrie ont pu être conquis
en quelques semaines comment
Mossou 2e ville d'Irak de 3 millions
d'habitants a-t-elle pu être prise en
quelques heures d'où est issue cette
force motorisée comment toute cette
logistique a-t-elle pu être mise en
place certes il y a eu des prises de
guerre aux armées syriennes et
iraakiennes mais personne n'imaginait
une telle montée en puissance la carence
des services de renseignement entau est
vraiment stupéfiante et très
alarmante nous fumes donc contraint de
déclencher l'opération Chamal dans
l'urgence notre réaction fut
émotionnelle et improvisée maintenant
nous devons nous engager dans une action
réfléchie coordonnant tous les
adversaires de daesh avec un seul
objectif le détruire il faut détruire
daesh pour des raisons humanitaires afin
de protéger les populations locales
faire cesser les massacres abominables
de milliers de chrétiens de Yazidi de
sunit modéré de cheit faire cesser les
viols et le commerce de petites filles
il faut détruire daesh pour des raisons
de sécurité
intérieure combien de Kashi de Koulibali
présents sur notre sol équipé de
Kalatchnikov de RPG d'explosifs par les
cellules dormantes sont prêt à exécuter
des policiers des Juifs des journalistes
nous nen savons rien on évalue entre
1500 les djihadistes français de daesh
sans doute plus selon les Kurdes qui les
affrontent en effet on peut se rendre en
Irak et en Syrie par avion et être
repéré mais aussi en voiture en train en
bateau sans lettrre on ne peut être que
très alarmé chers collègues par un
sondage même indicatif selon lequel
25 % 25 % des 18 25 ans éprouveraiit de
la sympathie pour
daesh daesh a su s'adapter aux frappes
aériennes en se mêlant à la population
des villes et des villages il est donc
absolument impossible de l'éradiquer
sans force au sol quelles sont les
forces au sol qui peuvent être mise en
œuvre on a constaté à Mossou la piètre
qualité de l'armée Iraki
on ne peut compter sur les forces du
golf et de l'Arabie Saoudite peu
conséquente et de plus parce que sunit
elles ne se battront pas contre d'IT
d'autres sunites au côté de chit les
États-Unis ne veulent que positionner
des forces spéciales et à cheminer des
équipements lourds pour les pêmerga car
le président Obama craint trop
l'enlisement et ne rééditera pas les
erreurs commises en Afghanistan et la
désastreuse campagne d'Irak les forces
britanniques épuisées sur ces mêmes
théâtres d'opération ne peuvent ni ne
veulent envoyer des troupes au sol les
Opex absorbent la quasittalité de nos
forces disponibles et même si nous nous
voulions il nous nous serait impossible
de faire plus que l'envoi de quelques
conseillers et de forces
spéciales pour éliminer daesh nous
devons remettre en cause un certain
nombre d'AP priori et ne pas oublier la
responsabilité de ceux de notre camp qui
ont contribué à sa jeunesse quelles sont
les forces qui peuvent se battre au sol
les Kurdes nous aidons en arme lourde et
conseiller les curbes d'irac les
pêchmerg ils sont en phase de reconquête
de leur territoire mais depuis 2003 ils
sont en état de paix et ont perdu hormis
la garde présidentielle une partie de
leur
efficacité en effet sous la poussée de
daesh après la prise de Mossou herbil
aurait pu et aurait dû tomber c'est la
garde présidentielle du président
Barzani appuyé par le PKK renforcé par
les armes lourdes iraniennes et les
frappes américaines qui ont brisé
l'offensive ce sont eux aussi qui ont
évité avec leur branch syrienne du PID
que cobané ne soit prise le PKK est la
force la plus effic sur le terrain mais
nous ne coopérons avec lui que de façon
occulte car il est considéré comme une
organisation
terroriste depuis 30 ans un conflit très
meurtrier oppose le gouvernement turc et
le PKK il a provoqué près de 45000
victimes des soldats turcs des membres
du PKK mais aussi la destruction de 4000
villages kurdes le terrible danger que
représente daesh et notre objectif
d'efficacité doivent amener notre
diplomatie à œuvrer pour que les
négociations pour la paix qui se déroule
entre le PKK et la Turquie
aboutisseent nous devons aussi
convaincre la Turquie de participer
activement ne serait-ce que du fait de
sa longue frontière avec les théâtres
d'opération ce sont là des éléments
majeurs pour venir à bout de daesh ayons
en mémoire pour contrib
à sortir le PKK de la liste des
organisations terroristes que la
frontière entre résistant et terroriste
s'effacee souvent dans le temps
rappelons-nous que l'Israélien menaem
bin et le palestinien Yasser Arafat
considéré et pour chasser comme
terroriste reçurent tous deux le prix
Nobel de la paix les pchmerga le PKK le
PID ont stoppé l'offensive de DAEs mais
ils ne sont pas en mesure de reconquérir
les 200000 km qu'ils contrôl la seule
force capable de le faire c'est l'Iran
il lutte en Syrie contre l'Armée
islamique par l'intermédiaire du
Hezbollah il effectue des frappes
aériennes en Irak et approvisionne les
milices chiites en armes les pasaran
sont présents en norme la mort d'un de
leurs généraux démontre l'importance de
leur engagement
nous avons hérité de relations
exécrables avec l'Iran certaines
justifiées et d'autres moins
convaincante elles ont surtout pour
origine la révolution islamique de
1979 faire la guerre pour la gagner
c'est porter au plus haut le pragmatisme
pour éradiquer daesh quel autre solution
qu'une coordination avec l'Iran elle
sera certainement difficile car cela
représentera un véritable adournamento
pour notre diplomatie ajoutons-y le très
sensible dossier nucléaire mais elle
serait pragmatique et courageuse elle
incarnerait à nouveau la capacité de
notre diplomatie à s'émanciper tel le
général de Gaulle reconnaissant la Chine
en 1962 en pleine guerre du Vietnam et
le président shak refusant de participer
à la guerre contre l'Irak en 2003
faisons preuve d'autonomie quel est
notre poids dans la coalition
participons-nous aux décisions notre
contribution militaire fortement
symbolique n'est aujourd'hui que mineur
mais nous pouvons jouer demain un rôle
politique majeur par notre action
diplomatique dans notre action pour
coordonner les acteurs nous devons
introduire aussi la Russie et la Turquie
dans le débat nous devons avoir la
volonté d'engager des négociations avec
l'Iran
puissance régionale incontournable avec
laquelle nous entretenions des liens
privilégiés nous devons l'inciter et
l'aider à trouver sa place dans le débat
international cela permettrait de plus
d'y améliorer les droits CIVIS nous
devons élargir à la Syrie comme nos
alliés les frappes aériennes sous peine
de faire de ce pays un sanctuaire pour
daesh et cela malgré notre failité au
régime de Bachar al-Assad il faut savoir
choisir poursuivons l'opération Chamal
en élargissant donc à la Syrie
poursuivons les livraisons directes
d'armes lourdes au Kurdes d'Irak la
présence des forces spéciales des fes
arignennes participons bien sûr à la
reconstruction de l'armée iraakienne et
coordonnons-nous avec les forces
loogales ennemie irréductible de daesh
lespiss le PKK le PID et l'Iran c'est
notre seule option pour que notre action
en Irak humanitaire et sécuritaire
tourne à notre
avantage il n'y a pas de domaine où il
faut être plus pragmatique que la guerre
réalisons que si on se refuse à coopérer
avec les Iraniens et si on se refuse
d'agir en Syrie l'opération Chamal ne
mettra pas de fa aujourd'hui la guerre
est sur notre sol pour la gagner en
France il faut d'abord la gagner en Irak
et en Syrie c'est pourquoi le groupe udi
votera la prolongation de notre
intervention en Irak merci mon cher
collègue la parole est au président
Bruno
retaillot monsieur le Président euh
messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères
défense voilà euh donc pour cette séance
cet après-midi autour cette séance ce
débat autour de la prolongation de
l'intervention militaire française en
Irak vous avez donc pu suivre cet
après-midi à la fois l'hommage aux
victimes des attentats de la semaine
dernière et puis le début de ce débat
sur l'Irak tout de suite on va faire le
point sur cette actualité politique et
parlementaire très très forte
aujourd'hui avec vous Delphine Girard
oui et bien effectivement merci perine
on va tout de suite revenir sur les
temps forts de cette journée dans 24h
Céna le journal c'est tout de
suite